Mm,
and we live.
Yeah.
What are you doing over there,
Joey?
Just looking at your book.
I've been reading that book lately.
This message one,
which one I even talked about on the
podcast,
the war of art resistance.
So now I catch myself every time I'm.
I want to do something.
I catch myself.
I've been practicing for look at the
resistance levels that comes up like
different things I need to do.
I want to see what excuse I get myself.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a normal thing,
right?
Normal Ms dot white brother.
Very nice to meet you.
Coming down here man.
I hear the fantastic things about you
from Joey,
from other people.
So Joey insisted.
He's like,
you've got to get this guy in.
He had dog.
He's a fucking wizard.
What he did for my shoulders.
What?
What did he do for your shoulders?
You know,
I've been going to Alberto.
Alberto Alberto cranes is the man in
Burbank for tactical fitness.
Right?
They do it in the mornings in the
afternoon,
but the one kid coach Robert,
you know,
after class he would say,
Joe,
what are you gonna do you gonna go home
or you want to do this for a little
while and at first or first two weeks
the movements were difficult,
but then,
you know,
level one stuff,
man,
any age could do it.
If I could do it.
Just laying on the back,
lifting your hips and spending over on
your toes and doing it back.
And at first I couldn't even look Joe.
I couldn't move my elbows like that.
Nothing.
My shoulders,
my wrists,
and I kept staying for the 30 minute
thing.
Five exercises,
three minutes apiece.
That's it.
No drama.
You could be big,
heavy.
It's all stuff I could do.
Picking up your leg,
putting it on body weight or body
weight,
stuff that I can handle.
If I can handle it on my risk being 300
pounds,
anybody can handle it.
Simple stuff.
And one day I was getting caught and
like,
uh,
the guy was pulling me into his guard
and magically my hips flew up and I just
mysteriously gotten to site control and
I,
something made me look up and Alberto
cranes jaw dropped and he goes,
that's from doing that stuff.
You couldn't do that when you walked in
here.
But I kept going to these 30 minute
things.
Thirty minute five exercises,
three minutes.
You're out of there at 1:45.
So it was this a,
uh,
like a.
do you have like a system that you bring
to a bunch of different places and you
have a affiliates?
Is that work?
I'm going us right up to you.
Alright,
sorry.
I suppose that for me.
Have you ever done a podcast?
You speak fantastic English for someone
who's from Italy,
right?
Thanks.
I believe in.
I lived here years ago,
years ago,
got married years ago.
Spent some time,
be careful.
Trump might kick you out now.
You got to be super careful.
I already been out back in Europe.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So I'm representing this system has been
by Asana.
Oh Scott.
Simon.
So it's like
cloud that CSD,
uh,
we meet each other a long time ago in
[inaudible] 94 and then,
um,
I was doing contractor work that's worth
my time of businesses design.
I've always been involved in training
martial art and any kind of training and
that,
you know,
or the injury that got for competing and
normal weight lifting and I'd been lost
contact with him for a few years and
then I saw him in 2000 and coming out
with the clubbers club has really
attracted me.
It was a different tools and I say,
okay,
I want,
I,
I'll give you bake in concert with these
guys.
I want to understand how can they,
can help it.
So I went back to him and he blew my
mind,
blew my mind and helped me to get back
into the best shape of my life.
You know,
I feel now in 47 feet I can move better
and do better than I used to do it when
I was 20.
So I promised him,
you know,
I'm going to make these things happen in
Europe or you want me,
my coach,
you changed my fee,
my way to see fitness and I got to do
that.
So between my job and security I was
introducing this to my teams,
to my teams and then I see changing on
people,
people being able even to just to go,
moving easier,
you know,
and then transfer to whatever it was,
our training and Ghana or wherever
skiers and stop everything was easier.
So I start to believe,
start to believe basically,
and I start to say,
okay,
I want to help more people that I can in
my line of duty in the army because I
still don't have a different contract as
a consultant in the army.
Back home has a physical trainer and
some time out.
So non combat training and I start to
introduce these things from barely cry
because the system is very complex as
they were.
Joe was talking about is all the
mobility.
Yeah.
Mobility is a big.
It's a big factor because there's for so
long,
people have just been concentrating on
getting stronger or getting in great
shape,
but I,
you know,
I know people that are in fantastic
shape,
they can run forever,
but they could barely touch their toes
and you,
you,
you developed these bodies that are
severely limited in the amount of motion
that you can actually get out of your
body in certain motions.
You're really good.
You know,
you could,
you might be explosive with a bench
press,
you might,
you might have a great run,
but whatever else you're doing to your
body,
you're compromising all of your overall
mobility.
So over the last few years has been a
tremendous amount of concentration and
effort by a bunch of different trainers.
Kelly start,
he's a.
he's done a lot.
Kelly's done a lot of work and his book
becoming a supple Leopard.
Excellent book on that and Kelly has a
great instagram you can follow to and
what he's done is he's done an amazing
job in highlighting mobility and how
important mobility and just having a
full range of motion,
which seems so simple,
but it's not something that most people
really concentrate on.
Most people are concentrating on getting
stronger,
more deadlift,
more bench press,
more this,
more that,
but you're compromising all of these
different areas.
Your body absolutely
agree with you.
That's,
that's from the right,
right there.
This ball,
that ball right there is the um,
it's,
it's one of those,
I think he calls it the Wad.
Supernova.
Supernovas.
So I got that one too.
It seems like nothing.
But when you roll around and find this
spot,
release tension on your Fascia.
Yeah,
put that on the ground.
And I do like bridges on it.
I lie on my back on it and I put all my
weight on that ball for people just
listening.
It's a rubber ball that's like the size
of a softball and it's really hard and
it's got like this textured outer
surface.
And Kelly developed this to,
uh,
to help you.
He also uses lacrosse balls.
That's what I start out with.
But then I think that's a little bit
better than a Lacrosse ball.
I take one of those everywhere with me
on the road.
Every time I go in a hotel room that
goes in my bag period.
Like there's no.
Because if I work out I get stiff.
If I got something locked up,
I need that fucking thing.
That's what I have to in my bag because
it will to travel and flight flight.
My deaf friends being back,
my lower back have the same problem.
I find those links.
Went to St.
Yeah.
Like say Joe,
what is the bodies were the things years
ago to take a unit of my community,
you know,
working with the army or stuff like
that.
They say,
oh,
we're going to do mobility.
They will look at you like,
do we really need that?
You know,
the old tough guy,
you know,
the old thinking about need something to
get myself stronger and faster.
Yeah.
But they don't get it.
They don't get a few who don't allow
yourself to regain their mobility.
Yes.
They used to push to have.
At one point you're going to be stuck.
You're going to be reaching blood door,
you're going to get injured and you're
going to lose those guys in the field.
That was my point and I think the system
that this got created was smart enough
to say,
you know what?
I got introduced this slowly underneath
because they give you this amount of
mobility that I w what you want when you
want to have that intensity workout,
okay,
should I give you that I intend to do
about that doctorate,
I intensity,
but you're going to teach you how to
recover for the poor performance faster,
and then I get introduced to Libya of
Yoga,
so you're gonna.
Feel better.
Loosen up when you live in and day by
day,
those guys,
they on understood and they started
telling me,
you know what?
We like the workout,
but what we feel we need to be able to
move the shoot that again,
to be able to carry a backpack again and
now everybody wants to do mobility more
than workout because you can kill
yourself in the workout.
You don't even need to kill.
You just throw the days and decide to be
a push up and that they don't need to
really someone to drive you.
Here.
People are understanding now that it's
a.
it's a huge deal and yoga is huge.
For me.
That's one of the reasons why I still
use that Supernova ball,
but man,
Yoga has had a tremendous effect on my
back.
Is that a tremendous effects on
everything?
My overall flexibility is better than
it's been in a long time since I was a
kid and I just feel better.
Just feels like everything moves better,
you know?
But you say yoga to and they go,
ah,
you fucking pussy.
How come they're doing dead lifts?
You need to do fucking hill sprints.
You know,
everybody wants to do something that
looks like tough guy.
Stuff that looks awesome on your
instagram.
You know,
everybody wants to do dead lifts for
fucking full of 50,
but the reality is if your body has any
weak links,
yoga,
we'll find those links,
show it,
show it right away.
I was shocked like,
you know what the big one for me was my
feet and then this is something that
nick curse onset as well.
Nick [inaudible],
who is a really well respected strength
and conditioning coach,
a speed of sport down in,
uh,
I think he's in Huntington beach
somewhere in Orange County,
but he trains a Joe Schilling Hoffeld
dos Anjos,
Fabrizio,
Verdugo pick time,
MMA fighters and kick boxers and works
with Aaron Peko was a top level wrestler
and just a long line of like real high
level combat sports athletes.
And I asked him,
I go,
what do you think that the one thing
that a lot of athletes have that is
something they need to improve on?
He said,
feet strength.
Nobody says that.
Everybody's like,
work on your cardio,
work on your explosiveness.
You got to be able to,
you know,
fucking throw more kettle bells around.
He was like,
your feet,
like you think about it,
your emotion,
like if you can't move out of the way or
towards your opponent,
you're useless.
Right?
If your foot's broken in a fight,
you're severely limited and one of the
things that I found out almost instantly
when I started doing yoga and when I
started skiing,
my fucking feet would be killing me in
the beginning.
Skiing was because my boots were too
small because I have really wide feet so
my feet would be smashed in there and it
sucked and I was like,
well fuck skiing.
I can't do it.
My feet are too wide.
Then I got boots that are made for a
wider feet and they fit,
but my feet would still hurt.
After awhile I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with my damn
feet?
Maybe it's just because my feet are flat
and I'm just going to have to deal with
that.
No.
As soon as I started doing yoga,
now I can ski all day.
It doesn't bother me at all.
As long as I'm doing yoga twice a week,
all that foot problems are gone.
They're out the window because a
balance.
It's pretty funny because I was watching
you flow video the other night right
before I came on because I didn't have.
I wanted to be able to contribute in
this conversation.
You guys are to level genius for me,
so if you want just flow video.
The first thing he put on some shoes
with toes with them and you're talking
about the feet.
That's before you do anything.
He started stretching his feet and I
could see him playing with his toes and
I'm like,
you know,
I guess this is the.
I think it was going to say and it's
saying this,
but this has got to be just pulled
around and be great.
Is there anything.
You know what I mean?
Everything.
Everybody don't think about it because
we stand in our fit so we think we're
connected to the earth.
We are not.
We just post this one on the table but
he's not connected and move around,
but it has no control.
We're building the capability to grow,
grabbing the ground,
understand the stability of the food,
the mobility of the tours,
and the ankle mobility is mandatory
because I'm going to transfer power
through my fit engagement to the
ground,
to my leg,
drive to my hips to enter my core.
So everything comes from the hurt.
These shoes make everybody look gay.
Uh,
yeah man.
There's no way around the shoes.
I love them.
They're very functional,
but they're not sexy at all.
I will never get married with us.
Well,
I always know the real weirdos when I
catch them out at night and they're
wearing them,
you know,
if you catch a guy like at a bar and
he's wearing those shoes,
that's a real weirdo.
But there's people that do wear though.
Is that your gym?
What gym is that?
My exec said Jim.
Yeah.
As the gym that I'm dealing with,
I'm working with in Europe.
That's the,
that's my headquarters say in Europe.
So it's a,
it's my dream.
So this is all what we're looking at
here.
What's the name of this video?
Jamie?
Flow fit,
flow,
fit,
tactic.
Flow fit.
Alberto.
Gutsy.
Vibram five fingers,
so you sponsored by Vibram or I'm an.
I'm an ambassador for them and I'm a and
that's a very low profile one.
It has a very small amount of tread at
the bottom of it.
Right.
It's very thin.
The one that you've got on because there
are different,
different type,
different types.
Some of them are for trail running.
I tried to work with them to,
to,
to realize something specifically for
flow because sometime when they have
uber on the side.
Yeah,
so specifically flow.
Especially if we want to focus on your
knee and understanding of my knee and my
hips work,
they get too much friction.
So why do you use that instead of a
barefoot?
I go,
I have to donate it.
Like you felt you wanted to really go
freestyle and move around.
You know,
I go freestyle go barefoot,
but food,
there's no traction but some.
But it's,
you know,
if I train them like a Doosan time in
the concrete,
I need somebody to really protect them
in dirt and rocks and stuff.
Like that.
Years ago you told me one of your
biggest failures was getting old and
feeling weak,
you know,
and then you and I traveled a lot
together.
A lot of places.
We would go to Jujitsu places and we'd
see the Jujitsu Guy,
the main guy,
and he'd be walking a little funny.
Yeah,
they're all fucked up or he be.
And that always stuck out,
stuck out in my mind like why love
something so much in my sixties,
I'm going to be limping or walking
different and I think this is maybe the
so help.
That definitely helped that I think.
Yeah,
that's one of the reasons why it has
gotten so into yoga too and he's doing
yoga three times a week now and he
realizes that after he had back surgery,
you know what I mean?
Once you,
when people get older in particular,
you start realizing the limitations of
some of the things that you're doing.
You're putting tremendous stress on your
body in very specific areas,
especially Jujitsu.
You're attacking the joints all the
time.
You're attacking the joints,
you're attacking your neck and almost
everybody that I know either has a back
problem or some sort of a knee problem
or a neck problem.
It's just a constant issue when it comes
to Jujitsu and I feel like the only way
to mitigate that as first of all roll
with people that you know,
like people that you know,
they're good people.
They're not going to try to hurt you.
They're not crazy.
It's not even their fault,
but young people in could get like some
young 20 year old kid is all full of
fucking just come and just some little
animal they want to kill.
They want to kill a young guy.
When they roll,
they roll fucking full clip and you you
could get a knee caught in a scramble
and it gets ripped apart.
It's a super common,
so you gotta be real careful.
The kind of people you work out with,
make sure that people aren't gonna Yank
on an arm bar,
a knee bar,
he'll hook or something like that.
That's big,
but also I think that improving your
mobility,
like dude,
there's so many times.
I would go to class and I would be stiff
before I walked in the door right before
I walked in the door.
My back would be fucked up.
I'd get more up in the morning.
My back would be just be stiff and then
it get in there and start warming up.
But Jujitsu,
so fun.
As soon as you get in there,
you just do a little few movements.
He started coming in on flammatory,
so you ready to go?
Next thing you know,
you'll like slap hands and you fucking
go into Oregon and then you got a worse
back.
Then you've got a worse name.
That's how I fucked up my back.
I didn't just fuck it up in one thing.
If I had.
That was one incident that had got
injured in,
I could have eventually healed it.
What I did was I just kept doing it.
Even when I was still hurt.
I would keep God,
God just go light.
I never went light.
Still go back in there and go hard again
and then fucks it up more.
It's.
I think that we have to be super aware
that our body is a precious resource and
you got to treat it almost
scientifically instead of looking at it
like,
you know,
guys like to do curls and bench presses
because I mean,
how many times have you seen that where
you see a guy with a meatball upper body
with little toothpick at the bottom
that's holding them up with his legs.
Like you see guys are certain guys you
see at the gym and you go,
you poor bastard.
Like what are you doing to yourself?
Like you think everything looks good.
He's got these big biceps and big chest,
but your lower body is virtually
useless,
you know,
because they don't live.
They don't live with their lower body.
They don't do anything with it.
You don't.
She got to treat your body like,
like it's a big old science project.
You know,
like the.
You have to look at it scientifically.
What I.
When people ask me,
what do you think?
You know what I think,
what is the project that I'm not going
to train you?
I'm thinking,
oh,
it was that everybody of us,
we know what is our point b.
So if I asked you when you come to the
gym,
what is Yoga?
Most of the,
especially young people,
they know I want to be.
Nobody's my point be I want to become a
foster,
a stronger leaner,
whatever you say,
point b,
point a to point B.
Yeah.
We don't really know what is our point
a,
we think we know what we don't know.
We don't know what's going on inside our
truck about estrogen and testosterone
and cortisol,
whatever.
We don't know exactly over the Fascia
has asked me to set up with us.
If you don't think about that,
we never going to reach point and oh
probably we're going to reach it,
but going zigzag instead to go straight
line and we're going to face in what
injury plateau.
Back to the,
you know,
imbalances imbalances.
So that's why I think the difficult.
Something like yoga is very important.
It highlights those
imbalances.
It seems like this kind of particular
motion,
like your flow like that up there.
That would also highlight those
particular modules.
I see.
I see flow like for me at the beginning
of everything.
Why?
Because you go through the lab or joint
mobility and then you start to connect
to exercise logically and connected to
what challenges your breathing so you're
breathing will tell you exactly when
you're forcing your brain to some of the
moment.
You should start to understand the
investigative.
Why do I force through this range of
motion?
Probably something is stiff for me.
Maybe my giant might be my Fascia.
Whatever it does allow me to flow
through one one to the other moment
because I'm working six degree.
I don't just work in their life,
a yoga mat up and down,
left and right and just to roll jumper
score to wherever is my body she
supposed to be doing.
I look like,
like if you know the magic guys picture
for me,
the message guy,
Peter,
the one that you look and then you step
back and the guy picture.
For me,
it's the body.
You know when I see you standing or do a
couple of moment,
I can interpret that yourself a little
bit,
but when you move freestyle,
now I can understand exactly what what's
going on with you.
Do you drop your knee when you score 10
and do a.
You know you don't do.
Your feet is not connected.
You cannot talk your knee when you.
You can know even understanding loading
one side,
you need lateral power in order to
wildlife,
to the other.
So for information,
that's for me as a coach,
okay,
I start to plan out what should be doing
or kind of exercise.
What kind of strength training maybe is
neither for you more stability or more
more yoga because until you are already,
I wouldn't know like Chula lift to load
your body if your body's not able to in
your own way.
Well that's the thing.
Most people don't know what their body's
capable of doing like and there's a lot
of people that walk into any kind of a
classmate start working out and they
might not even know what deficiencies
they have because they've been
overcompensating for that.
Or compensating,
you know,
you might have something wrong with your
hip and because of that it's putting
extra pressures on your knee or you
know,
one side might be over.
That's one thing that you see with a lot
of people that have done very specific
sports,
like they're very strong on one side and
then the other side of their body is
weak and when you do that,
you create these imbalances.
You can get some serious injuries
because
of that.
So we take it for granted.
The time you say,
okay,
I wish my shoulder is in pain,
but when I,
when I trade,
no good,
it's already the senior,
you know,
you're training what you're going to do.
Are you going to release the adrenaline
and cortisol and that.
Those are painkiller that they are
supposed to make you stronger.
You know,
fight in the freezer,
fight situation.
That's what is the endocrine system is
doing to you.
But after your training,
you got even worse than you to
understand that there's a coach.
You should be saying,
now what?
We need to fix that because it's no good
that you start training and working into
the pain because you were going to
create more raw material.
There is no neither into your body and
for me it's like holding this bottle
doesn't wait nothing today,
tomorrow,
but if I order for one hour,
this becoming heavy so we adapt to this
kind of similar and they didn't change
the level of the water in my butter,
but day after day is going to kill me,
but people don't understand because they
say,
oh,
I'm used to.
I used to do,
don't sleep.
Used to do,
don't eat enough.
I'm used to to,
to work in this pain.
That's not going to happen now.
What do you think is the biggest injury
that you deal with when you have clients
or people that you're working out with?
What's the most common as it shoulder,
shoulder and the shoulder?
More common those days,
especially because we,
we become,
we all grew up in the era that we all
want to,
you know,
pack and a stroller.
Now press presses and I believe our
shoulders are complex joint,
but it's not strong at all because we
were vertical animal,
not like chimpanzees.
The destructor is holding back.
The horse can hold a lot of power in the
shoulder,
the human,
be sure that it's just dropping on the
ribcage,
so awake and then simple question is,
are many of us can even stand,
just stand standing on the wall with the
feet on the wall.
Some people that can even hold their
weight,
give me.
You're saying to do handstands,
just even simple like that and how many
people,
even with the fit and the world can do
an instant press.
Yeah.
Not that many.
And if you ask how many of you,
10 or 10 out of 10 got shoulder injury
probably denied.
They say,
yeah,
I've got an issue since I've been in
school.
So wic is very complex.
A lot of tendons and ligaments,
multiple joints.
Do you incorporate a lot of hanging?
Um,
I think hanging is something that people
have been really concentrating on over
the last few years for shoulder mobility
and alleviating impingements absolutely.
And people listening to this,
if you have anything going on with your
shoulder,
some talent,
you grab a chin up bar and hanging from
that thing and just relaxes your
shoulder.
It stretches out your joints and there's
several doctors that stopped doing
shoulder surgeries and to alleviate pain
they've started doing hanging exercises
and prescribing hanging exercises.
It's amazing.
Just grab a chin up bar.
Start hanging from that soccer history
though.
He has the with the class structure 12,
but I got 11.
It's not like a formula.
The class I go back to the jump rope and
just to get oxygen power so I don't pass
out.
But Alberto come back,
they're like 11,
15 and give me homework assignments and
they're always different.
Joe,
like some days it's a steel club.
Sundays I'm just working on my hands and
knees and we incorporate our hips,
but some days he puts me on rings.
He goes,
you got rings at Your House,
Wrangler mastics rings.
I go,
what wall is going to hold me?
I mean,
he's got the whole thing and he just
taught me one thing too,
because my biggest weakness is my
breathing from the sleep apnea.
Like I even got hypnotized.
I mean,
I got to go tomorrow,
yet you got hypnotized,
been going to get hypnotized.
What's going on with the sleep apnea?
You ever wake up with your pants down?
No,
no,
no.
I got it.
Got So severe minds is such a bad case
from my machine broke a couple of weeks
ago.
My wife had to go pick up the machine
for me up in Logan.
The guy was saying,
how's Joey doing?
You know?
And he goes,
you know,
that til this day,
Joe,
he came in here as one of the worst
cases like Joe,
he was in bad shape.
You
remember what I was going through the
sleep on your steering wheel and,
and uh,
that sleep apnea,
like whenever my heart gets going and
Jujitsu like no other places,
my heart,
they're gone like that when I'm on the
bottom.
And that's all.
At first when I joined Jujitsu,
I overcame the panic attacks.
So I had to just go stand on the bottom,
like I forced myself to get on the
bottom.
I kept like a,
whatever you call it,
a bridge or whatever they call it a
frame and I breathe and I overcame my
fear.
But the other fear I had was when I get
to round up,
I can't control my breathing.
It's when I get up from their sleep
apnea.
So I just,
I kept thinking about something you said
about a couple of podcasts ago,
but a sports,
uh,
sports,
psychiatry is something.
Sports psychologist,
some people have it and I did some
reading and I said,
let me just go alleviate this last fit.
I mean,
how many feet you,
I got the needle for you.
But last week I got,
you know,
I still get that thing in my ear.
She stuck a needle in my ear.
Acupuncture,
they take the fluid out because my ear
is not letting my right,
my left ear,
the Florida.
So either they've got to put fluids in
there just from we're taking showers,
you know me,
I'm obsessed with showers and I got
plenty of plugs in my ears when I go in
the shower and I go in there for an hour
when you know,
when California had the drought,
I go to Vegas,
I got one of those king size pin shouts.
I smoked a joint going there for an hour
and a half.
I read jokes.
Oh yeah.
I love taking long showers,
shower material.
Really your best material level,
you can even practice it in that
fluid stuck in my ear.
And last week I went to acupuncture and
she stuck a needle in there and when she
took it out,
it relieved the pressure.
Joe,
I could feel the blood dripping down my
face and I could hear it hitting the
pillow and I didn't pass out.
Oh,
I want to get these fears a little way
back to tactical fitness.
The rings,
he has rings and Alberto taught me
emotion that it's all about my
breathing.
I don't leave my ass on the floor.
So I basically pick up my hips as a hip
escape and in the same.
Then I hold that breath,
but I pulled myself up.
I stay there and then I as I leave my
hips back is when I exhale and then my
arms go down on that one.
So it's a two point breathing thing,
dog.
I do three sets of 10 of those.
I'm on fire after that.
Yeah.
I'm a big believer in that.
Fire
breathing is gigantic.
It's another thing that seems so simple,
right?
It's another thing you tell people,
oh,
you got to do some breathing exercises.
People that I'm not doing that shit.
I'm doing bench and bro going to build
up my pecs,
bro.
Right?
That's what people do.
They don't.
They don't think that breathing is
difficult,
but breathing exercises I.
This is what I tell people.
Breathe in for one minute and breathe
out for one minute.
Tell me that's not hard.
Just take a one minute breath in,
look at a clock and say ready,
go.
And then breathe in for one solid
minute,
nice and slow,
and then breathe out for one minute.
Nice and slow.
You'll be fucking dead.
You're not going to be able to do it.
Most people can hold their breath for a
minute.
If you tell them to breathe in for one
solid minute,
it's really hard to do,
but then you go to like a yoga class and
you take,
you know,
Yoga,
deep breathing,
Pranayama exercises.
They're very difficult and one of the
things that I.
When I first started doing yoga,
like about two years ago,
I really started getting into it again.
The,
the,
the breathing exercises after class when
you like,
when you're doing those breathing
exercises.
It was like my stomach felt soft.
It felt like it was kind of weak.
Like you would get tired doing those.
I'm like,
why is my.
And I was like,
I'm just tired from Yoga.
Like why is my stomach getting tired
from breathing out?
Like pushing air out.
It's so simple.
Like I do sit ups and leg lifts and all
this different stuff.
Like why is that difficult?
Because it's a different kind of thing
and you're breathing,
you're pushing air out with your
diaphragm and your abdominal muscles.
But now I could do it pretty good and,
but you get to like that Hicks and
Gracie Point,
I'm sure you've seen that pull in the
muscles up in these weird ways and make
them dance and it's so connected.
Brain brain is connected to your
breeding,
the heart granted to your breathing and
understanding what's important to regain
access to proper breathing.
Yeah.
Even for people to think,
okay,
breeding for meditation.
No into the olive.
No pre written is good for everything.
He's visualizing what she needed to do
it.
They know reset.
You can switch from your pressing.
But that the theory of the sympathetic
and parasympathetic.
Yeah,
never sees him.
You know,
it's like you breathe correctly,
especially on the stress and the you
need to regain access to your community
president.
Especially if you need to do something
that is more complex and you think about
it.
Some people that just thinking,
okay,
under,
under the gas response,
you know when my,
my father Fraser fight or flight and the
tuition is on.
Okay.
I probably go to my gross motor skills.
Yeah.
But some people like an advanced fight
that on a an operator,
they need to go to access to gross motor
skills and fine motor skills.
Think about,
I'm going to run across this room.
I need to use my gross motor,
skipped over on foster,
but I need to understand what am I going
to find covert and maybe shooting back
to a target.
So now you have final the skates on and
gross motor skills.
Any to be able to get my product
vertical view because I can't explain my
tuna.
So hold on.
Let's let your English was tripping.
That's okay.
I see.
What you're talking about is a big motor
skills like running and sprinting and
then being able to shoot a gun up and be
very precise and very accurate,
which is an the outfit interpret that
enables the people shooting at me from
so complex.
Complex.
So do you have guys do that?
Do you have guys like lift weights and
then go or do licks,
strenuous physical exercises then go
immediately to a range or honoring?
We do that,
but also,
you know,
when we will start with what is the
importance
of,
um,
learning how to recover fast to using
the breathing recovery Britain,
like the tactical breathing in some feel
like you were talking about some they
never see,
they used to do a lot for me and it's a
44 seconds in,
four seconds,
four seconds on a very basic way to
learn how to get back from the
intensities to above your Ra Max tool,
let's say 85 percent something that you
can bring you back to a cognitive
presence so you can make the right
decision.
So that's what you tell people to do.
Take a four second end and for second
out.
So you're like slow controlling of the
breathing.
That's the beginning of understanding
because we're going to be,
when it would be going to start going
into my nose and maybe taking a post,
go out to my mind.
So the,
my iris would be in through the nose,
out through the mouth.
Yeah.
That does seem to somehow or another
slow down your heart rate for some
reason.
Exactly.
And that's your slow down.
He's going to give you a senior back to
your brain.
Okay.
Now we switched our finances under
control so you can make the right
decision.
You can get back to the the final
discussion that if it's needed right
then that obviously with when you're
training soldiers,
it's got to be one of the most important
things to do to be able to operate under
pressure and under physical pressure and
make the right choice.
Yes,
that's different.
You know,
they're not panicking.
The survival response would tell you do
the things that maybe it's more logical
to save your life,
but sometimes like I always use this
example,
we're going to cross the street right
now.
You're going to cross,
you see the car,
you're going to freeze,
and then you're deciding,
jump back or jump forward,
whatever is your response to see.
Don't get hit by the car.
Right?
But it may take like 12 milliseconds in.
If you've been training more to that
kind of alarm,
you're going to see the car and you want
to do before you jump in and out.
You're going to look and see on the
other side because maybe you see the
car,
you jump back,
you didn't see the car coming from
another part and you get killed for the
Ellicott that take our response of 300
millisecond,
so it's the Amiga will tell you to do
whatever is needed to get out from the
problem faster,
but the long way of your brain response,
if you've been training,
you become resilient to the alarm and
shock situation.
You're going to make the right choice
and for an operator,
for a fight or whatever,
it's a logical thing about Jujitsu,
a chess game,
chess game,
even those guys to play chess.
So under stress,
our brain is cooking and the guys make a
move and maybe me,
but they're not playing and just,
you know,
I see the move.
I see I got moved this way.
The other guy's planning with taking
more time to plan whatever is going on
because you start to understand why you
did that move.
So it's not a logical for me,
I shouldn't be going that way.
And in training regarding access to your
breath,
into your right,
to your brain,
control is fundamental.
That's why I believe we need to be
careful and understand fitness is so
important.
We can do a lot of things.
It's not just changing our other way.
They look.
We can add different people in different
things.
For some people it's life changing.
You had the ability to be calm under
pressure is something that very few
people have and they just don't.
They don't.
It's not something that they exercise.
They don't get to do it on a regular
basis.
They don't get severely stressed so that
when they are in a severe stress
situation and they have to make a
critical decision or they have to use
fine motor skills in a critical
situation,
most people are just completely
incapable of handling that.
That'll emotional and physiological load
or what is it about.
There's something interesting about
breathing in through your mouth that
creates like a panic feeling.
Like when guys are tired.
Yeah.
Like what is.
I don't understand.
Like it's a shallow breathing thing that
happens.
Yeah.
They took too much air in.
I believe that's what it is in the
brace,
the province,
they bring clamp up called the,
we call it like a,
like a fourth leg to into the fear
reaction and so for your brain,
while you bracing,
bracing where you don't know,
something you never expecting.
So for my brain,
my data bases say he's been there before
in your life,
you'd be freezing for something and they
will bring you back.
Okay,
this is a fierce situation,
so your sympathetic system is on and you
start to lose control.
Hit that panic mode.
I think it's so simple.
You know how many time you let you touch
your when when you're under stress or
under the assumption you know you'll be
losing control of your.
Maybe you.
We fight.
We have a discussion,
very intensive discussion and you can
touch your lace.
So
breathing in.
One of the things that you really
learned that during yoga class in
various particularly stressful
situations,
it's so hard to breathe smooth.
It's one of the.
One of the things that I've learned how
to do is to try to concentrate only on
my breath and it actually makes the
exercise easier,
which doesn't seem to make any sense
because before I would just be
concentrating on the exercise and what I
realized somewhere along the line is my
breath is not very smooth and I'm not
doing a good job of controlling myself.
So now when I'm in a situation like a
really difficult like standing bow pose
or something like that,
what I concentrated on more than
anything more even than the posture is
just my breathing concentrate on big,
slow,
deep breaths and I swear it makes it
like 10 percent easier.
Just concentrating on the breathing
makes everything easier.
And Chrome Gracie said that too.
When he was in here.
We were talking about Jujitsu and he's
like,
it's breath.
Breath is everything.
And once you can control your breath,
when you understand how to control your
breath,
it makes those positions better,
makes Jujitsu easier.
It makes everything better.
So your breath control your breath,
Jolie,
and you say that,
I think you know what?
I allowed all of us.
We know how to brace.
Are we talking for half an hour?
We never stop it and do it while we're
talking,
but we're not under stress to do the
problem is what people.
They don't know how to excel.
If you take amend and put it under the
water with the head,
right,
what is the last things is going to do
before you die?
When it gets to breathing,
so the body.
Exactly know when it's time to inhale.
It doesn't know how to.
When it's time to exhale.
That's fear.
That's where we didn't have to force
people.
Hyperventilate.
Like my six year old gets upset about
things.
Sometimes she hyperventilates like she
just can't get it out.
Like she's upset.
Like someone did this to me,
you know,
and you've got to go,
okay,
you got to calm down.
I want you to take some big deep
breaths,
but it's hard to teach a six year old
doesn't know what the fuck do we do on
stage for breathing?
Just talk about.
I never thought about it like I started
getting anxiety at the store.
So now when I walk up to the original
room,
like on Tuesdays or when I did the
wheelchair and I forced myself to
breathe in and out of my nose,
but for years we're excited at the
store.
Yeah.
And the original launch I've been back.
I don't know.
It all started.
I had a follow Morgan Murphy.
I don't know.
I went up there,
she was on stage and I don't know what
it is.
I just get anxiety and the original room
just a little bit,
just a little bit.
And at the wiltern theater I walked out
and I looked that way and then I looked
at the audience and it was like woo.
And I had to breathe through my nose,
but what did we do on stage?
Are we breathing through our nose or are
we breathing through our mouth?
We fucking talk shit for 45,
one hour.
I looked at the special shot.
I'm like,
where am I breathing?
Yeah.
How interesting that we got to watch
that next time.
What the fuck are we doing up there?
Yeah.
You're not thinking.
You're just breathing.
Yeah.
Will you just concentrated so much on
what you're trying to say that it all
just comes natural.
Just like right now while I'm talking to
you right now.
I like.
I took a little breath right there,
but I wasn't thinking about it.
I just don't want any.
I want to get a little bit of air.
Right,
right,
right.
Because it's so natural for you.
Maybe take me on a conference the first
time and wasn't going to be shaking and
go around into my ward and then you see
that from people that are given speeches
and you do see that when they've not
become comfortable with public speaking.
Public speaking is one of the most
stressful things for people.
For some people like number two or
number one in some people's world,
like it's really bad.
I had one.
One time a judge asked me,
he was about to sentence me and he goes,
do you ever say these for yourself?
And I had it written down.
I had everything.
Joe Rogan.
I started tweaking.
He was like,
don't worry about it.
Pan.
I couldn't talk.
I went right into a panic when this
little man looked at me,
but people get nervous,
you know,
and when you get nervous your adrenaline
kicks in and when your adrenaline kicks
in,
everything tightens it,
you know,
just you know,
and physiological stress like yoga
positions can kind of mimic that.
Like when you were in a position like
when you got your hands over
your head and you're leaning your whole
body to the side,
it's very hard to stay smooth with your
breathing when you're in those spots.
Like that's the number one thing that I
concentrate on holding my body in that
position is not nearly as hard as
holding my body and breathing smoothly.
Breathing smoothly is the most difficult
part of that posture,
like a lot of pasta,
and as soon as it's changed your
breathing,
you started to changing inside and then
you change it outside.
I see.
I see that happening.
A lot of you know I love was the first
reaction when you're under stress,
tension,
but for four,
if you look back there or what happened
when you were in the pre storia phrase,
three prehistory,
greatest thing about it,
that you are a prey.
What you're doing.
Yeah,
like any animal,
like a cat in the road and the road they
start to pump.
This is hair hot,
become bigger.
Right?
So that's what we doing.
We growing our shapes so the product
might look at as like,
oh,
we're too big.
I'm going to attack a simple,
simple prayer.
We try to,
you know,
our,
our skin start to trickle in Sanford,
like nice pumps.
We,
yeah,
we don't have hair,
but we start to do the same.
Maybe the same example.
Goosebumps are.
It's like your hair's figure.
That's interesting and if I look in how
come it's like that when you hear a good
song that's a different feeling.
It's like a lot of people,
they misinterpret it or the old thinking
that we thought,
okay,
we go tactical training,
we do this and we can control a fear
reaction to different things.
You can control when you are really
under stress for the kind of situation,
so our rate for years and other things,
matter of fact,
I I intensity workout.
You become erad under fear.
You become important,
so it's different.
Different physiological things going
into your into your body,
so they all things that people didn't
want.
Any misunderstanding that doing some
kind of a high intensity workout we can
control also the fear,
real fear because real fears and other
things.
Well,
one of the things you see with fighters
is they perform better when they're more
active,
when they fight more often.
So if the fighter fights like three
times a year,
they're used to fighting every few
months and they get that feeling of
competition becomes a normal natural
thing for them.
And it's also something that happens
when you see a fight or lose.
When you see a fighter losing and they
come back,
they were very tense and they fight.
A lot of times they fight different
because they're.
They're now worried and concerned about
the consequences of failure and you see
that that fear,
that tension,
it's in their system and then they their
whole,
their whole mode of operating as a.
As a,
as an athlete changes because of that
tension.
There's the dinner to Cobra for the
shot,
for this situation they'd been through.
Sure,
and that's all.
Also one of the biggest factors when you
talk about the difference between the
way someone performs in the gym versus
the way someone performs in competition.
We've all known these guys that were
phenomenal in the gym,
but for whatever reason they weren't
able to win in competition.
It's so common.
It's with some guys.
It's almost like like it's crazy.
It's almost like there's a spell on them
or something like you'll see them in the
Jimmy,
like this guy is a world beater,
but they can't beat anybody in a.
In a competition.
It is psychological.
It's all psychological.
There they are imprisoned by their own
fears and doubts.
They don't have the confidence to rise
to the occasion.
They don't have the confidence to
perform under pressure.
They don't have the.
They can't just accept the potential
failure.
They can't.
They're so overwhelmed and imprisoned by
their fear of failure that when they get
out there,
they can't perform at their best.
It's crazy because it forces failure.
It's like a self fulfilling prophecy
because they can't perform like they do
in the gym.
They can't just react.
They can't flow.
Like when you were fighting,
when you're at your best,
you're sort of just in this empty space
like you're not.
You're not thinking about the moves as
much as they're just happening and
you're just relying on your training and
you're almost the best thing you do is
stay calm because as soon as you get
emotional,
as soon as you get aggressive,
you might win being emotional
aggressive.
You could catch someone and knock them
out,
but you also might get knocked out
yourself.
You might do something that's not smart
like when you're talking earlier about
playing chess.
Martial arts is a lot of ways,
like very much like chess,
but way more complicated because your
physical consequences are so severe,
so there's all this fear.
It's not just about losing.
It's about getting hit and that
punishment of physical consequences is
so significant.
It's so much different even than in
Jujitsu.
Jujitsu,
the physical consequences are tapping
and losing and those are terrible,
but it's nothing like getting kicked in
the face or getting one of those Yoel
Romero flying knees to your head.
You know,
that kind of fear is,
that's an overwhelming fear and for some
people they get a throw up when they're
in the locker room and they did panic
me,
they get so scared they just can't
perform under pressure.
You know,
you know,
if you could trust for this.
Also through some of the operator,
you know,
the,
some of the operator that literally
dump and when you say an operator,
you're talking about special ops guys
that the tough and didn't a super guys
know.
I'm amazed by those guys.
They just chapeau but there's naturally,
oh,
they don't do it in the task.
It might.
I might be shitting in my pants,
you know,
it's not physiological,
physiological and then you keep going,
just keep going with shit.
And that's the physiological reaction to
the stress factor.
Your body wants to get lighter,
to fight back faster or run away or
whatever.
You can control,
you know,
there's nothing to be ashamed about it.
You see it with animals as well.
I mean,
there's a famous video these two bears
fighting and as the bears are fighting,
they're,
they're shitting all over the place as
they're fighting,
they're shitting.
I,
uh,
I love watching movies like collateral
or something.
When people go into some place and they
shoot the place up and people's reaction
are they run.
That's not usually the case,
bro.
I've seen it.
People dropped on the fucking floor.
People dropped without even getting
shot.
They don't know what.
You just freeze the sound of you being
somewhere and being transferred to the
sounds of gunfire.
It's fucking overwhelming.
And some people get it and react to it.
And some people just think it's the
fourth of July.
Yeah.
You know,
it's really weird.
But I've seen people fucking dropped
from fear dropped from fear,
something that I was as a child when I
was two blocks away from just people
dropping from fear,
you know,
it's so like I remember when I lived in
Aspen,
they have the Esi body guard academy and
aspect.
What does that stand for?
I don't know.
But the guy supposedly was in a room six
by 12 room where they killed 12 Mexicans
at knife point with his bands.
So he opens up this Esi thing and it's,
you know,
it's 20 g's,
it's,
it's a summer long program and you learn
how to adjust up or die out the tube and
drive and evasive driving and shooting.
Then they have a course on maritime,
how to defend people out on the ocean
and all that stuff.
But uh,
she asked for it and all that,
those places like woody creek where you
went to his home,
to the baddest retired soldiers in the
world and you don't know who they are.
You just think that dude over there with
the American flag is mowing the lawn
that I killed.
80 people want to end them.
Bad Guy.
There's a guy endeavor that I know,
I'm telling you,
Colorado is where they put them.
Why,
why they put them in because the
mountains to keep them away from
civilization for these people just in
case they get Chinese music somewhere.
They don't ever want that to happen.
Break glass in case of war.
And there was a guy that came in that
was a marine that bro Joe,
you know,
anybody comes in with stories.
I know one thing when I see it,
I believe it.
The motherfucker used to get picked up
at Aspen and put him in the helicopter
though.
Like they sent like a helicopter with
two guys jumping out for guys around
them and he was just waiting.
But uncle Joey,
I was 19 and he would tell me stories
about,
you know,
the green berets and all these guys were
sitting around a thing cooking chili and
they will all tell telling how many
people they killed killed 18.
I killed 22.
Meanwhile he was stirring the soup with
this big over the fire.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's,
that's the type of stories this guy
would tell me.
He had me all fucked up in the head and
I asked him once I go,
should I go to that Esi?
And he goes,
listen,
I go in there and smack them all with my
left hand.
If he goes,
first of all,
you can't teach what you need to learn
over there because four years of Charlie
and the Bush is a lot better than 12
weeks of you hanging out with some white
dudes with suits,
shooting people targets and it's not
real.
It's not until there's real
consequences.
So that's why he said it just wasn't.
Don't you think
though it's better than nothing?
I would think that it's better than
nothing.
I would think that the best thing would
be actually being in bootcamp,
actually going to bud's actually being
in some sort of a situation.
We realized this is life,
this is real.
Whereas if you're,
if you're preparing like up in Colorado
and you just go through that course,
you might have some things in your mind,
but that's one of the things like people
say to me like,
like,
should I take a self defense class?
Like when they show you how to kick
somebody in the name,
I go,
listen to me.
That shit is not going to like,
there was,
there was a guy on the fucking radio
that was,
he was always talking about,
uh,
um,
it was on opiod anthony show back in the
day and he was always talking about this
difference between the street and a
martial arts and martial arts
tournaments.
There's no rules in the street.
There's no rules.
And I'm like,
I fucking hate when people say that kind
of Shit because listen to me,
the stuff that works on trained killers
is the real shit.
And if you think that you're going to
come in and you're going to throw some
fucking karate,
chop someone's balls and you're going to
somehow or another be able to stop
Anderson Silva from kicking you across
the room.
You're out of your fucking mind,
you're out of your mind.
You,
first of all,
you're not going to karate chop his
balls.
He's not going to let you get close
enough to him,
and if he does let you get close enough
to him,
he's going to strangle you and you're
not gonna.
Be able to do a goddamn thing about it.
You're going to be a 100 percent
helpless.
So this,
these ideas that there's a shortcut and
the shortcut is like street defense.
There's a certain pressure points around
your neck.
I could attack that and you will be
helpless.
No,
no,
no.
You're not going to get my neck.
You father,
let me grab your finger.
Uh,
yeah.
There was a guy at the store he used to
pinch down on literally the,
this is the biggest phony I've ever met
in all my years of meeting phony martial
arts guys.
He used to pinch down on your thumbnail.
He was like,
there's a pressure point and your thumb,
like motherfucker do lie on me with
their knee on my neck.
Like they'll put all their weight on
your neck to try to get you to give up
the arm bar.
Like if you're in a situation where
you're defending,
it's an art bar and the guy's on top,
you guys will put their fucking knee a
tour and 30 pound man will put his knee
on your neck while he's trying to and
it'll put all his weight on it and
you're not.
You're not tapping from that.
You think I'm going to tap from a
thumbnail.
It's funny.
I.
So people try to get into the,
especially for community and try to
teach them pressure points.
Do you realize this guy's wedding,
waterproof jacket?
The material,
you're not going to even access to the
body.
It's crazy.
There's so many stupid martial arts
courses and it's so.
It's so fucking dumb.
It's so dumb.
There's so many,
these ridiculous ideas that you're going
to be able to defend yourself with some
tricks.
But you know,
you were saying the cod people,
people that love these things,
you know,
like shit,
I have six bucks.
Yeah,
I mean there's training day in six weeks
or whatever.
Late night infomercials that you only
have 15 minutes,
but 15 minutes is two minutes too much.
Thirteen minutes.
It's all you need.
All you need is 13 minutes and you're
like,
wow.
That's what I've been waiting for.
I want to be shredded.
Great.
In the beach.
Thirteen minutes.
Fuck the fuck Outta here.
You've had a civilization of just these
big thick pills,
which are just things that a quick
fixes.
You know,
if you stay up past one,
it's,
it's all attacking men.
Testosterone level.
I don't know what it is about people
after one.
I'm fucking tired.
We're all tired.
Yeah.
So with sleeping.
Yeah,
but those guys that are up late at
night,
they just look like half a half.
Add resistance is down.
Do you have more sex drive?
I mean they just sell you some fucking
bill of lading,
whether it's the big dick pills or the
six minute workout and then they keep
beating each other like by one minute we
have the sick,
but we have the five minute workout and
you know what man?
Half of America buys into that.
A lot of America buys into the sap
pills.
That's the sad thing.
And once again,
if you want me to go back to what we
discussed before,
it's not about us.
So you know,
you're breathing out,
comfortable.
You on the situation.
I always give because I believe I've
been there.
I don't know you guys,
but sometime you want,
you desire to date someone so badly and
you get so excited when you get it and
the first day that you go,
you feel like you cannot even move,
you know,
panic.
And if you remember that day,
it doesn't work the way that you want
to.
You,
you pray,
they go to work,
but after you pass the first shot.
But the second,
the third is become better.
It's exercising and breathing control.
These are the same,
you know,
once you get used to,
everything's comfortable.
It's just,
that's a big thing with again,
what we were talking about with
fighting.
When I,
when I,
um,
I had one time where I tore a muscle.
I didn't compete for like six months.
It was like the longest time I'd ever
gone without competing because I tore
the muscle that connects the groin to
like,
um,
I think it's called a Satorius muscle.
It's like at the top of the leg.
It was real bad.
I couldn't throw any kicks at all.
I can only do my workouts in the pool
was pretty bad.
And so when I was recovering from that,
when I got back in the,
my first fight back,
I was like,
wow,
it just feels so off.
My timing feels off.
Everything feels weird.
But then I fought again less than a
month later and I felt great like less
than a month later.
Everything was like,
all right,
I know this again,
this is,
this is my thing.
I've been here before.
And then it felt normal again.
It's like when you were,
when you have a girlfriend,
if you have a girlfriend for a long
time,
you don't get nervous about whether or
not you're going to get it up.
You don't panic.
Like we hope she looked at me.
She fucking likes you.
She's naked,
she's right there.
She's been with you forever.
You know,
she likes you so it's not,
it's not an issue,
but if you know,
if it is,
like you said,
a curl that you've been thinking about
for the longest time and you're only
going to grow and I hope those schools
will whoop and then you finally get
weather like this panic and the,
the human penis is such a fucking odd
thing in that regard.
You know,
that's what a bizarre thing.
It's designed to make sure like,
look dude,
if you ain't come,
you're not going to fuck.
Okay.
Because we don't want any weak ass
nervous
bitches out there make it babies.
So the system is built to make sure that
you're an addict is not get hard if you
fucking panicking.
It's not like,
it's not like a Rhino Horn were armed
and ready at all times.
No,
it's not like a very specific
physiological process has to be in place
with the softest part of your body
becomes hard,
like a fucking rock like that.
The process itself is crazy.
When you look at your Dick,
when you go into p and it's this soft
little spongy thing,
and then you grab your Dick when it's at
full mast and it's like,
how is it the same thing?
Because it's this crazy physiological
process that only works if you're ready
to rock.
Uh,
you,
you can't be faking it like you,
your body knows if you're panicking,
right?
You,
it,
there's a book,
I don't know how you translate it in
English,
but this is a book of this plane.
So was so simple about those reactions
with the body under stress.
And he say,
think about the Zebra on the savannah.
You know,
that's exactly.
when you have someone that's choosing
you to hit you and when you are under
stress,
I stress your body stops.
Stop producing hormones like
testosterone.
Why you don't the last thing you want to
have sex and when some lions behind you.
So that's exactly what he's doing is
shutting down whatever is needed,
shutting down everything under stress.
You know,
when you are freaking out,
you can perform.
We can portfolio.
No,
actually I'll,
confidentially zebras are so bizarre
because the you see the way their body
looks like they're not camouflage at all
like white with black stripes on and for
the longest time they thought that the
white with black stripes on would
confuse and animals mind.
Like there's a type of Cammo.
Have you ever heard of a sat cammo as a
type of camouflage?
It doesn't look like trees or anything.
It's just a bunch of black and brown
lines and those lines for animals
because animals there,
their eyes operate on edge detection.
They operate on a lot of them,
especially prey animals like deer and
things along those lines.
They're,
they,
they see movement.
They don't necessarily see things the
way you see things.
They mostly just see movement and so for
the longest time they thought,
well maybe when you're looking like a
lion is looking at a zebra,
the lion is seeing the zebras body and
there's all the lines confused so he
can't see it.
Then they realized,
no,
no.
What it actually is is you can't pick
out individually zebras.
So like if an individual zebra like it
looks different from the other zebras,
that's the one that they get after,
like if one's ears bleeding and as blood
on his body and it looks different from
all those other white and black lines.
That's the one they targeted,
which is kind of fucked.
And one of the ways they found out this,
they tagged a zebra,
they put like an ear tag on a zebra and
they sent Jordan Peterson was talking
about this recently in this video and
uh,
they put it back into the herd and the
lines immediately killed at Zebra.
That's the one they went right to
because it had something different.
Like did you see all this book?
White and black lines?
And then,
oh,
this motherfucker's got an ear tag,
get them.
And he just went right after that.
So it's,
it's really designed like,
look,
we know we're get,
we're fucked,
we're born fucked.
But if we stay together,
you know,
maybe with like look when you see that.
So when you see all those ears together,
it's super confusing.
While we will have this fucking TV fixed
soon,
I swear I'm this,
this,
this TV cuts in and out that one pack.
So when you see these zebras and we see
these lines,
what it's designed to do is confuse the
lions so that they don't know which one
to target,
which is crazy,
but if one of those motherfuckers had an
ear tag,
a big old yellow tag hanging off their
ear,
the lines would be like,
there you are a bitch.
I see you.
That's kind of cool.
It's fun though.
I mean,
what a,
what a terrible situation.
Nature has given these poor things.
The lions are camouflaged.
The lions look like that.
The brown grasses,
you know,
and leopard or excuse me,
a tiger's apparently that whole stripe
thing with them is also to make them
blend in with all their surroundings,
all the trees and the sticks.
You know,
they live mostly in the jungle.
So you were asking me before this about
the fights this weekend.
What do you think would be good context
that occurred?
That's why they keep.
Well,
they'd know except that it's.
This is what I think a lot of people
were like pissed off.
It was boring,
but I think that's because they just
want to see people beat the fuck out of
each other,
which I understand.
That's why you tune into cage fighting.
But to me,
the way I always described martial arts
is it's high level problem solving with
dire physical consequences.
And if you run in on Tyron Woodley,
you got some dire physical consequences.
He's a fucking powerhouse.
And if Woodley charges at Thompson,
this dire physical consequences because
he was getting tagged when he would he
need said it to me after the fight.
He's like,
he caught me a few times as I was
charging towards him.
So Woodley has a different style and
Thompson Thompson has that wide stance,
that karate style and he's excellent at
moving in and moving out and almost like
point fighting you.
He just jabbing you,
hitting you with these,
uh,
clean,
lefthand sliding out of the way.
Occasionally throwing kicks.
But mostly what he's doing is making you
wonder what he's going to do.
And when he's coming at you and woody
had to pick his battles and figure out
when he could launch himself,
Adam.
So at any moment something could have
happened,
but a lot of shit didn't happen.
So the people watching at home like that
was the most boring fight over.
It's because those moments are so
critical.
Those moments are so dangerous.
You can't just.
They would like it to be like Frankie
Edgar Gray Maynard,
just fucking chaos or punches thrown
wild.
Not going to happen like that.
You can't do that with wonderboy.
You can't charge at him like that.
He will fucking counter you and you
look,
you will be one of those people on his
highlight reel.
So tyron Woodley was very smart and that
he knew that he couldn't charge Adam and
wonderboy.
He's not going to charge a willy either.
I mean he got almost knocked the fuck
out.
And the first fight he almost got
knocked the fuck out.
And in the fifth round of the second
fight to Woodley's a powerhouse man,
he hits so God damn hard.
So everybody had to be on their toes.
They both had to be minding their p's
and q's and that translated for a boring
fight to a lot of people,
but not to me.
To me,
I was like,
anything could happen at any moment in
the fifth round or almost did when,
when,
when Woodley connected and Thompson's
knees went out,
I mean he slumped.
He was out,
man.
He was out for at least a half,
a second or a moment,
you know,
there was a moment where his legs gave
out.
His body went limp and they could've
stopped the fight right there.
I'm glad they didn't.
Glad they kept going.
I talked to a big John McCarthy in the
cage after the fight ago.
How close we are to stop with that
fight.
He goes,
he goes,
I wasn't close to stopping that fight.
I go,
what?
You were looking,
right?
He goes,
I was looking go.
You were looking to close.
He goes,
I'll never admitted it goes,
but it was.
I mean,
he was almost out right.
He goes,
he was almost out.
It might have been out for half a
second,
but he,
I gave him a chance.
I go,
you did a great job.
He did an amazing job.
I mean that's why big John Mccarthy so
important.
That guy with that kind of experience
and if he fucked that up everybody would
be so mad at him.
But he did it perfect.
It was perfect.
He has the most difficult job in the
sport other than the fighters.
Fighters have the most difficult job.
Second most difficult job is the
referee.
Third most difficult job is the judges
really?
So I think so.
Yeah.
I believe is going to interpret that
trauma for the other people.
Well he has to be.
He has to look.
He has to be at the right angle.
Like they're moving around and they're
fast and they could go to his left and
he can be over here,
but something could be happening.
I'm there.
Right.
And he doesn't even see it.
You know,
you don't know,
like sometimes sometimes guys don't see
taps.
Sometimes guys don't see a certain I
pokes or groin shots.
There's a lot of things that can happen.
A referee's job is insanely difficult
and they only get praised when they fuck
up.
They only rather get attention when they
fuck up.
They don't get any praise when they do a
great job and just just they need more.
They need more.
More people need to understand like how
difficult that is,
so that moment where tyron finally did
connect on wonderboy and everybody's
like,
why didn't you do that earlier?
Because you could have got knocked the
fuck out.
Like that was where the opening was.
Woodley was so aggressive because he was
down on the score cards at least in his
corner of his eyes and in my eyes.
He was as well and he had a charge
forward and he had to connect and he
did,
but to make that happen,
a lot of things have to be in place.
You have to understand wonder boys
timing.
He had been fighting him for four rounds
already.
He was getting a sense of what wonder
boy could and couldn't do.
He also knew the consequences.
He'd been tagged a couple of times so he
knew like I can't just rush at them
because wonderboy was trying to tie them
with that right hook.
He was standing on the South Pole
position with his right leg forward.
He throws that front side kick to the
body,
throws it really well because he,
he picks it up from the ground like low
and and sort of scoops up so you don't
see it coming until it's too late.
It might not be the most powerful
application of the front leg side kick,
but it's very.
It's very sneaky because he slides in
with that foot low and then it comes up
and stabs you and you don't know if it's
going to come up as a sidekick or if
it's going to go up and over your
shoulders around kick.
You don't know what he's doing.
He's so sneaky.
So tyron had to be very cautious and for
a lot of people it was very boring
because of that,
but I didn't think it was boring was
happening.
I was on the edge of my seat.
I was just like,
there are moments.
There's going to be moments when the
shit starts flying and in those moments,
that's where the fight becomes amazing,
but those guys are smart.
They're not dumb in the belt is so God
damn important.
When you have the belt,
you get to decide,
you fight all the best fighters,
you,
you make the money,
you know,
you get the opportunities for the big
money fights,
like the conor mcgregor type fights.
Those only happen if you have the belt.
If you don't have the belt,
nobody gives a fuck about you.
So for a guy like Tyron,
man,
that belt is everything.
For a guy like woody or a guy like a
wonderboy,
rather,
that belt is everything.
If you don't have that belt,
you make a fraction of what you make.
Like think about that,
fight that fight.
It's insanely close.
It was so close.
Dominick Cruz afterwards.
That's basically the same fight as the
first fight,
right?
It's like you could call if you've
called the first fight of draw,
you could easily call this fight a draw
and I agree with him in.
So that means that wonderboy and Woodley
are essentially like so closely matched
stylistically that it's a wash.
Right?
But meanwhile,
Woodley's the one who's the champion,
will,
he's the one who has the potential to
fight.
Conor McGregor Woodley is the one who
has a potential to fight Michael Bisping
or whoever who else he fights at
whatever he fights at and that is where
the money is.
So he's the guy who's going to get the
money.
Whereas wonderboy who essentially had a
draw with him prove that he was at least
close enough on one fight and just a
hair under the second fight,
he ma,
he's gonna,
make a fraction of what woodley mix
likely so that those consequences have
to be taken into consideration when
you're watching these guys fight,
is that they know there's a wind bonus
and there's a loss.
Like if you,
if you lose,
you get your show money,
you don't get a bonus,
but if you win,
you get twice the money.
Like a lot of guys have that way,
their contract is structured,
you know,
they'll make x if they win and they'll
make x plus x if they'll make x plus x
if they win.
But if they lose,
they only make x.
So they might have,
they might be getting $200,000 for the
flight,
but another $200,000 if they win,
that's a giant swing.
That's a big deal.
So they have to be really fucking
careful.
They don't make mistakes.
I don't like when bonuses,
man,
I don't like it.
I think those guys are trying to win
anyway.
They're trying to win.
I just,
I just think like especially in
particular in situations like that,
when fights are like that fucking
clothes,
like a judge can decide whether or not
you make an extra 200 grand or don't
like.
That seems crazy to me to do training
boxing a few a few weeks ago.
Right.
Back doing Jujitsu again too.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Yeah,
that's cool.
I was,
but I wasn't walking back last night at
the crane academy.
I was night.
I came back from Ventura,
was teaching a workshop and I need some
let go something.
I didn't want to lift weights.
The dojo empty.
Why every bags,
gloves,
et cetera.
Let's go.
Yeah,
that's cool as well.
Heavy bag I think is everybody would do
better if they had a heavy bag in the
garage.
Just go out there and hit that thing.
It feels good.
You don't even have to have great form.
Just go out there and hit it.
It's so good for your body to just
explode and just release tension and
stress.
And for people of like joint issues,
they have these water bags.
It's essentially a thick layer of um,
the outside is like a thick layer of
padding,
like a few inches of pad of foam.
And then inside of that as a water
bladder,
it's filled with water.
So when you punch like your boss,
your arm goes into it,
but you could really dig in and hit it
hard,
but it doesn't have the same impact on
your joints.
You don't feel it so much in your elbows
and your shoulders and stuff because it
was given to a creativity once in
Sicily,
you know,
ever been easily.
That was the first time last year I went
to Italy.
Cool.
Loved it.
They're like,
oh man.
I went to Rome,
went to the Vatican,
saw the Vatican.
We went to,
um,
what is the mountain area?
Donate Dolomite?
No,
goddammit.
Alpine.
We,
it was out near where the,
um,
where the volcano killed everybody.
Vesuvius.
Okay.
Yeah,
we went there and then we went to uh,
the Mafia.
Amalfi coast.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Oh Man.
Amazing.
So beautiful.
Didn't even seem real.
It seems like you were in front of a
green screen.
You look out,
you know you have to go on this mountain
roads.
Crazy.
Joey.
It's a road that should be one lane.
Should we one lane,
but it's too.
And there's pluses on it.
Fucking buses and motorcycles.
Assholes and motorcycle
weaving in and out of cars.
People in Italy.
Dr. Like fucking maniacs like you had
never seen.
We all know Italians are kinda crazy.
I'm mostly Italian.
And you're going to have the left hand
steering wheel.
It's regular.
Like regular.
Yeah.
It's only lefthand in England and Japan.
South Africa.
Yeah.
You got into the car with a left right
here.
Will Australia as well?
Australia.
It's fucking confusing as shit.
You're like,
where am I going on the wrong side.
If you have a.
If you didn't,
never,
never to driving.
Oh yeah.
Because you have the shift with your
left hand is.
Oh yeah,
but you,
you still love the clutch is still on
the lefthand side,
right?
And the pedal steel in the right to
adjust.
But it would be the opposite version.
Yeah.
So this is the what it's like on the
mouth of coast.
So you're driving on this road.
This is what it's like.
That's a two lane road jelly.
There's a fucking bus coming and you've
got to figure out how to get a car pass
that bus.
And we were going like,
and I'm not exaggerating,
half of a mile an hour
trying to get past cars and buses.
Absolutely.
It takes forever to get up there.
It should take 10 minutes.
That's the road.
It takes 90,
but once you get up to the top,
look at that picture.
Where you seeing the ocean?
Jamie?
Like up in the right hand corner.
Upper right?
Yeah.
Like they're,
that's what it looks like when you.
Once you finally get updated,
like wow,
it's so pretty.
So pretty man.
Italy's amazing.
The foods and the foods grow out of this
world.
Fuck your gluten.
You Bet.
All your gluten free bullshit.
We've got to let that go.
When you're in.
A lot of
people here say,
Nah,
you go at least nothing like that.
That's Americanized one.
It's more fish and stuff.
There's a lot of.
Well,
they definitely did a lot of fish.
Do they use,
do they still use gravy?
Like red sauce?
Not so much.
You could get it though and I think one
of the reasons why you can get it is
because probably people have come over
there and wanted it,
you know?
Do you remember that episode was a
prime.
That was with the guy who it.
He's like,
I want gravy and the one way to look at
the other one,
he goes,
he's east coast.
The talent's there was classes with the
Germans because he wanted spaghetti with
gravy.
Big Old.
Would you say gravy?
Like people are like,
what is he talking great.
Like people think of like gray.
No kids.
Yeah,
it was spaghetti sauce.
yeah,
yeah.
You can get Bolognese over there,
but what it,
it's just the Americans that came over,
they developed a different sort of style
of eating.
Like a lot of meatballs.
I got afraid though.
You don't like it when you come here as
an immigrant.
Like when I came from Cuba,
like when you're a white kid.
That's my,
my,
my daughter Likes Alfredo.
That shit's going to get cut off the
menu and like a month.
But you know,
my fucking world.
That's what people in Iowa.
That's the first Italian they eat.
Like how afraid you.
No,
no,
no.
That's like a one month training thing.
Like,
like I even had it out a little fucking
job.
Like that's how Alfredo was.
Yeah.
When I was.
When I came from Cuba and I've tasted
Italian for my mind blew up,
you know?
Um,
I was into all angles of it,
but the red sauce was last.
I'm afraid though with fucking those
thick noodle sauce I'd like to give to a
fucking horse.
But what it looked like,
chicken and Broccoli.
Mushrooms.
Come on.
Jamie's a good,
good.
You grow out of,
out of that.
It's not my first choice,
but I liked it.
I didn't ever heard about that since
when I moved here in 91,
92,
93.
Everybody was asking me,
do you like 15 afraid of saying I don't
even know.
That's hilarious.
No Italian.
I said not for me that
it's like going somewhere in another
country.
I can tell you just the cheeseburgers on
American one of the meals.
So you have bullet Asia,
but Robbie Yada have pacifiers rule you
about that,
you know that the location that they
call it.
No real name.
Like Pasta Fagioli yeah.
They don't call it pasta pasta for
little.
But then what's in the like we can't get
that stuff.
He encountered Doug.
What's that guy?
But go with one
the green stuff to stop and catch your
Dick hard.
I thought it was a blue.
What are you putting beans and um,
that the green stuff.
It's not pesto.
That's the best.
No,
it's not spinach.
What
they call.
It's two things.
So you're talking about a type of
vegetable x.
got old and being a girl gets you
deckard.
Huh?
I think you did was just getting harder
to make that shit.
November,
you know,
I ain't possible.
When I first tasted it,
I hated it every day for like 40 days.
Like when I first went to my house,
I went from one 60 to one 94,
just eating pasta for
me that's the only thing.
They were lifting weights and possible.
You get jokes Jack.
It's like taking the ball,
just pop those beans that's got old and
that in the winter with all that garlic
and stuff,
you're off and running.
I didn't have a lot of fish.
Like you had amazing drive by the Amalfi
coast.
They had amazing seafood,
but the pasta was like a very light
sauce.
Like a,
you know,
you get like if you go to a good place
and got like Linguini Vongole,
they'll give you a link with a very
light olive oil and garlic sauce with
the linguine and like that is the kind
of like.
It's a very much more a delicate pasta.
Yeah.
Because you're going to taste the fish
flavor.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's why if you try to go to a real
Italian restaurant,
you ask for cheese,
grated cheese on like Linguini vongole.
They'll look at you like you're a
fucking monster.
Who are you?
You're not going to put the cheese on
the top of the fish.
Yeah.
They'll say it's not recommend or not
recommend.
They look at you like,
don't do it,
and you're like,
Nah,
come on,
come on.
Hit me with it.
Like Kevin James and I used to always
get Linguini and clams and he would get
pissed if they didn't come home with a
cheese.
Like where's the guy with the cheese?
I've got to have the grated cheese.
And you would try to put it on like at a
good restaurant.
They would get.
They get upset with you.
I don't want you putting that cheese on
it.
If you have like,
like a spaghetti Bolognese or something
like that,
they'll,
they'll ask you next cheese then that
makes sense.
But they don't even come near you.
They'll try to stay away from your side
of the table.
If you've got linguine with clams,
they don't want.
They don't want to give it to you and
even red wine,
red wine with fish to get mad.
They get mad.
You're supposed to drink white wine was
really.
Yeah,
they get that upset with it.
I don't drink white wine.
Dry white wine.
I drink barely,
but red wine is better than y for me.
I mean I'll drink white,
but I don't order it.
Like if somebody pours me glad I'm not
going to.
It's not awful,
but if I have a choice,
it's always red.
I like red red.
To me it's like it's got a flavor that's
compelling.
It's interesting.
It's like,
it's like it's a lie and it's white wine
is like chick drink.
Sorry girls.
I drank a fucking.
My mom used to have a bar and she had
night and we'd go home when I was real
young,
like four or five in New York City and
my mom would have a little classroom red
wine,
the wine with the fucking Italian
paperwork on it that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like that shit.
So I was,
I was maybe four,
maybe five,
and I would watch her one night I
watched it go to bed and I said,
fuck it.
And I took that bottle of wine.
I fucking drank the whole thing.
She woke up like six hours later.
They couldn't find me.
Call the police.
I was missing.
You were drunk as fuck and the closet
shit.
Pew.
I never drank wine again three years
ago.
Smell.
It's still get sick.
I got sick.
I remember she telling me all the time,
you will never like one because you got
so hammered.
That time.
We called the cops.
We did everything.
They couldn't fucking find you a burger.
What's your martial arts background?
I started with boxing.
Regular boxing.
Then I find that that time it was like
82 a big things easily was full contact.
Karate,
those big named Ben.
Ben.
Ben,
Ben of the Gender Akita is out here,
man.
He's from me.
I used to train his gym when I first
came here.
When it first came to California,
Jedi blank.
De Blank was done in.
And the palisade.
I believe this guy though.
Yeah,
she blinky Rodriguez,
he was out here as well.
He's Benny's brother-in-law that's stuck
with that and then we tie came and fell
in love.
That's why my voice is my big thing for
that more type.
Fucking change everybody's eyes.
As soon as you realize how hard it is to
get kicked in the leg.
Well.
Oh wait,
what?
Yeah,
that was,
I was like,
everybody,
you know,
it never try know.
The first time I went in to say,
okay,
what is it going to be?
Nothing different,
you know,
it's like being around that was kicking
the legs and they hate me.
I remember I couldn't walk for a couple
of days and man fall in love.
So like more dyes that are competing
with karate style,
with the Shin a,
whether we're the instep rather you
kicking with the top of the foot.
Everybody had this idea like that was
the way to do it.
And then the moment you get kicked with
a Shin you go,
oh,
that's a.
and they got a lot of injury for kicking
on the East App.
Oh yeah.
On my ankle was.
Yeah,
he was devastated.
So need to recondition your mind like we
discussed in the beginning of a Shin
kick change.
Then during the past,
you know,
for,
for the skewer to investigate different
style,
different and
defend.
The guy that changed my,
my way to see things transferred,
not to competition or to,
to to my line of duty was a guy in
Israel,
but it's because it's been into for war
three.
A man is like,
become like a second father for me.
And he always told me,
you know,
it's the spirit.
I don't care the way that you punch,
the way you kicking in until your
mindset is not on point,
he's not going to be the not going to be
ready to do something for real.
You know,
it's so that they can tell you,
do carotid,
do Jujitsu,
do they do that?
But if your mindset,
real things,
when you go to war,
you do you need to apply these fins for
change.
I think he's right,
but he's also not right because I think
he's right in the sense that your
mindset must be correct in order for you
to apply any,
any sort of martial arts in
international competition.
Absolutely,
but it's always important to have the
right technique.
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
no.
I don't miss.
Maybe I miss same.
Israel was working on already on.
He never believed in.
Is there an Israeli guy he say
introduced the Jujitsu a lot,
introduce to do the Bj Bjj and his
system to do the bottle or the box and
we tie,
so you need to have the full aspect of
that.
And then of course if you go into the
Australian special forces there,
the secret service and you need to have
the right guy to do that.
Some people are not ready to be a
warrior.
Can train like a warrior now warrior.
Yeah.
I can only imagine.
Especially like Krav Maga in the United
States,
there's legit Krav Maga schools in the
United States for sure.
There's really good instruction is
really good,
but there's also a lot of fucking
horseshit.
Just like with karate,
like there's a lot of mall karate where
you go to these places and they might be
fine for little kids.
They're learning little martial arts,
learning,
little discipline,
they have goals,
you know,
I want to get my orange belt and they
get it and they get excited and it's
good for them.
It's good for their mind,
but it's,
it's,
it's really critical when you're
learning a martial art,
one of the most important thing is to
find a legitimate instructor.
It's the most important thing because
relearning things is so hard.
Back when I was teaching,
when I taught someone,
they didn't know.
If they didn't know anything,
they came to me with no martial arts
experience.
It was so much easier than if someone
came to me with bad martial arts
experience because if you have a.
like if he took karate for a few years
from some Bozo and you did everything
all wrong,
I would have to reteach you so when you
would panic,
if you would get nervous,
you would go right back to that old way.
Like as soon as someone puts the
pressure on you,
you would go right back to the old
shitty technique.
That's exactly what it's still about.
What is your learning and the movement
that is in your brain is the same
position or whatever you will achieve a
you put into the other way is wrong.
You're under stress.
Is gonna repeat the same face.
That's where the everything man,
even for pool,
like there's certain techniques that
people learn where they don't learn how
to do pool correctly.
You only playing billiards,
you stand the wrong way and you get used
to it and when you're in a match and
there's a lot on the line,
you go right back to the old ways.
Even if you take lessons like it's so
important that when you learn things in
life to learn them right the first time.
That's why when you're growing up as a
human being,
I think it's been an issue with me.
I think it's been an issue with you as
well.
When you.
Your childhood is kind of fucking crazy.
Like you develop these ways of thinking
and acting as a child that are very
difficult to break as you get older and
you get as an adult,
it's like you have this foundation
that's a very faulty and you have to be
cognizantly aware.
You have to be consciously aware of
that.
Okay,
this foundation is fucked up because I
grew up with domestic violence and I
grew up with no dad and so I have to
make sure that I don't fall into these
patterns that I had established in my
head when I was eight,
nine and 10 and 11.
You know,
as you're growing up as a,
as an adult,
this is the way you're looking at life
and then you have to kind of
restructure.
It almost sounds like you're starting
over,
but if you meet someone who has like a
great father and a great mother and they
grow up and they have like a great
fundamental balance by this.
Those people used to always make me
nervous when I was a kid because I was
always like,
God,
like these.
I don't even know anybody like that.
I got on.
I don't like,
I would feel like inferior to them,
like when I was around people that had a
good childhood,
I would feel inferior.
I still do.
You sure?
I feel.
I feel weird if I like I have,
I have friends that I think about them
now when I go,
I want to really interview their parents
like what did they do to get this kid to
be such a fucking?
What was the recipe to get this child to
be fucking superhuman being,
and I'm not talking about Julia
servings,
father or fucking gsps debt.
I'm talking about people who you meet in
life that I really fair,
that are really kind.
I look at those people and I go,
I wondered what their parents did with
that.
Mike.
Good to have that ability to want to
help people and go out of that way.
You know,
I always think about that shit.
Especially now as a parent,
you're like,
what is the fucking chemistry of love
for them to understand?
You know,
we were talking on the way up there when
my mother died,
you know,
it was the seventies and let's face it,
we were still specs and that New Jersey
neighborhood,
you know,
in Boston and those areas,
you hear things,
but I remember those Italian kids coming
to my mom's wake and they couldn't make
eye contact with me.
The same ones that would say spic or
whatever because I short circuited that.
I broke them because the number one
word,
admittedly his mama,
right.
That's it.
When you're in town and everything,
his Mama,
they would come to that wake and I would
short circuit them because they never
could think of that situation that
happened to them and I'm still friends
with those people today
and I always wondered why,
you know,
who raised him that that super great
people and then you come here to a place
like California and you meet people and
they have nice parents or whatever,
potentially the biggest scumbags in the
fucking world.
Do you follow them?
That's what interest me in my life.
I always feel like those people,
the parents probably weren't around that
much or I might be really nice people,
but they didn't,
they weren't around to really install
the right ideals and values and morals
in their system.
You know,
maybe the parents were off at fucking
swinger parties or some shit.
I always look at that,
you know,
with uh,
even the kids I grew up like I have a
friend that his dad was little but his
mother was solid.
And when you say his dad was a little,
you mean gang?
I'll put a bullet in your fucking eye
ball.
I'll put a bullet in your eyeball at
lunch,
you know,
I mean,
when I would hang out with them,
people's parents would come to me and
go,
I wouldn't be going over there if I was.
You really see the article on his dad?
Yeah.
Oh,
he's a psycho.
No,
no,
no.
He was a crazy.
We're just a street guy.
Okay.
And you know,
today the kid is one of my best friends.
Never had a problem,
never had a law problem.
Never.
No record,
never check it.
Married children.
Well,
you know,
there's people that grow up with
horrible environments and they come out
amazing and then their brothers and
sisters are all in jail.
It's weird how a person makes choices in
their life that really establishes their
entire life and a lot of that,
those choices,
man,
I hate to say it,
but it could be luck.
They could've made a lucky choice early
on and that lucky choice led them down a
better road than someone who's made,
made a poor choice.
Like kids that get involved in the
juvenile detention system when they're
really young boy that fucks them up.
So was a horrible,
horrible and a good friends can know
good people are on juveniles and again
continued the right things.
You know,
even even if it's hard when he's telling
you the truth and the of sounds like a
smack be on their ads,
but make you open your eyes.
Make you say,
you know what?
A kid,
once you put a kid in one of those
gladiator,
a prisons,
the percentages,
just like we were just talking about
that movie that came out of sleepers,
all four of them went away.
Two of them came out to become westies.
The other two came out to be decent.
The percentages,
it's 50 fucking percent.
Yeah,
and that's,
that's on the,
that's on the conservative side,
right into the higher you.
Once you get that first tattoo and smoke
that first cigarette,
all those things,
your percentages go deeper and deeper.
You know,
once you get the tattoo knuckles that
say fuck good,
Mike Tyson got the face tattoo at 40.
Everything had already all the bad stuff
out of his life.
He had already come through,
but it might Tyson with a cane with that
face tattoo at 18.
You know,
it's so weird.
Like how I saw it,
I saw people on the bottom
that today,
that successful in the police records
don't matter,
nothing matters.
Yeah.
And then I saw other people who were
like sneaky people who now they're in
trouble for tax evasion.
You know what I'm saying?
Like there's always.
Yeah,
my mother was a big things for me.
Like I said,
Mama,
my mind had been burned.
My mother,
she always told me to give it more that
you can do,
you want him to receive the Dapa.
And then it was a bit told me,
you know,
like be,
straight to people,
you know,
don't,
don't fort around yourself so you're not
going to force it on people.
And I believe that things,
you know.
Yeah.
It also helps if,
you know people that work hard.
When I was a kid,
um,
my,
my best friends had jobs and they worked
hard.
They were constantly working.
There were always working at a young
age.
Yeah.
My friend Jimmy and Jimmy Law,
I'm still buddies with them to this day,
but we were in high school.
I was fucking guys always worked in high
school and high school.
I always worked,
always worked at construction jobs,
always worked.
I had construction jobs too because my
dad was an architect.
My Stepdad,
um,
uh,
always set me up with these construction
crews and stuff.
So I did these jobs that we're in.
So it gave me the understanding that you
like,
like if you've never worked hard and you
don't know what the fuck hard work is,
then all of a sudden you're 18 and then
you're in college and then you got out
of college,
then you have to get a job.
You have no real experience with actual
difficult work.
I just don't think you appreciate what
it takes to get by and growing up,
seeing people that had a strong work
ethic and realizing that that wasn't
something that I had,
but maybe it was something that I need
to consider as being like a very
important skill,
a very important trait.
The ability to just actually get shit
done to get up in the morning when your
alarm clock goes off and go,
you're uncomfortable,
you want to stay in bed,
it's cold out.
You don't want to do it.
That,
that ability to just do it,
just get up and do it.
You know that old Nike slogan,
just do it.
It's one of the best fucking slogan of
all time.
You know what I mean?
People actually went out and worked out
just because that just do it.
That might've been like the most
effective ad campaign in the history of
ad campaigns when it came to actually
getting people to do things that are
uncomfortable and something that
actually made sense.
Just do it so fucking so important.
It's so important.
Just gotTa fucking get things done and
for so many people,
like you were talking about the
beginning of the podcast,
show me that book,
the war of art where it talks about
resistance.
There's so many people that just fuck
off.
They fuck off and they don't get the
things done that need to get done and
that haunts them.
We know it as comics.
We know so many guys that told write new
material.
They just don't.
They don't work.
You know why?
Because when you have new material man,
sometimes it doesn't go well.
Sometimes you bomb.
Sometimes you go up and it's clunky.
It's not ready and when you do a special
like will you just released a special.
You know what it's like,
you didn't need that materials
dead now and so now you have to write
all new material and you have a bunch of
people that are coming to pay to see
you.
Oh my God.
It's
always good.
Yeah.
I panicked every fucking week.
Every week when I go on the road I
panicked because I don't have a full 50
minutes of.
Nope.
I got a couple fucking minutes and I'm
trying out new shit constantly.
Constantly.
But can it comes together slowly but
surely together,
but it's just like anything else.
It's sticking with it.
Right now I'm in a slump.
So what do you do as a baseball player?
Jamie?
When you're in a slump,
what do you do as a baseball player?
You quit.
No,
you keep fucking hitting and you keep
striking out.
You keep fucking striking out and you
keep it together.
You cannot lose it.
I Eka Tony Perez,
1976 slash 75 against the Boston red
sox.
He went,
oh,
for 17 in the series and then game
seven,
he hit the single that chains.
They won the world series really?
So he could have just said,
I don't want to do it.
I know I'm going to comedian slump.
Well,
not anymore now,
but like in December and January it was
fucking heavy jack.
But you just got to work yourself
through it.
There's no other way to get yourself
It's.
There's no other way.
There's no other.
There's no other way you don't want.
And for me,
I could lie to you and say,
well,
I'm not going to get on stage.
I'm going to stay home and write for the
next three months.
That's not good enough.
Wrong answer,
Jack.
That's not going to work.
It's not going to know.
You've got to keep going to the well,
like right now I have a problem.
You know,
last year I have such a fear of being on
my back and Jujitsu that it really
fucking made me.
I will not quit.
I will not quit because what happens if
I'm on with Joe,
I'm with my family one day and I got
kicked in the stomach and I'm on my
back.
Am I going to panic so I cannot fucking
quit.
So I kept going back to digital,
but the weird thing was I was doing it
wrong even though I was putting in the
time I wasn't working on my breathing.
I thought that by me going three times a
week and doing what a fighter does,
stay in the and that fighting three
times a year that my breathing would
come together.
It will come together.
But then little not,
not good,
not good delivery.
Like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the time I put in for what I get
back wasn't rewarding enough.
Like I would think of going to a
different approach.
So.
And then I started doing those little
things with Alberto when the back when I
get there,
the breathing.
You know what man?
I'm a big boy now.
You don't have to tell me Dick.
I know I got something wrong with the
back of my head with that fear Shit and
it with the needles and what did I do
with the needles?
Dope.
I could faint,
faint.
Walking into a doctor's office.
I could smell cotton.
I can't smell shit.
I could smell fucking cotton.
Like walk into a doctor's office.
I could smell that.
Associates with fear.
Tremendous.
When I walk into a doctor's office,
my blood pressure is 190 over one 60
dogs.
They look at me and go,
how were you walking?
I go,
take a hike,
come back in 10 minutes.
And once my doctor comes back and
he starts talking to me and we talk
about Chicago beef sandwiches,
he goes,
watch this.
And it's 1:40 over 80.
I figured,
right?
I know,
I know.
I lived through this.
I lived through it.
It's a four.
It's all about for me,
when a train people,
you know,
I tried to say,
okay,
you're doing tempo shop and if you come
to the eight,
the number eight and you'll see that you
start to struggle.
Does that stop?
I don't allow you to do a bad number,
a number nine because I know number nine
is going to be a bad push up.
So.
But for them.
So what happened?
When you got to be under stress,
you're going to be repeating the best
for them.
So for me it's the constantly I try to
remap you,
like you said before,
when you were teaching,
remapping the way that you always try to
achieve the best.
So like you said,
just do it.
What I say.
Okay.
You need to repeat the things and to you
never do it wrong.
Don't do it right.
You'll never do wrong.
Right?
Once you can come from blackness is a
like shot,
I want you to learn how to do it right
every single time and that's when we can
step forward to the next level.
Do you subscribe to that?
Pavel Salini,
you know he's got that strong first.
Allow the ideology where you don't do,
you don't do the failure ever.
And I do that now.
So that's how I do all my work.
I don't,
I don't lift to failure ever.
Like say if I could do 10 reps or
something,
I do five and then I wait like 10
minutes and not do another five.
Then I'll wait 10 minutes,
I'll do another five.
They don't like 10 minutes.
And the idea being that it's more
important to do more workouts in the
week with low repetition than it is to
do a high repetition workout.
Like you know where the guy's like,
come on,
spot me last one.
That's not good.
Your body's not designed to do that.
Your body's not designed to be at
failure ever.
So what you're supposed to do is build
yourself up.
So you're doing these exercises and he
says that you should think of them as a
skill.
That strength strengthens a skill.
So each exercise you're doing,
you don't want to be tired when you're
doing a skill,
you don't want to be completely
exhausted when you're trying to pull
back a bow and Arrow or shoot a pool
game or shoot a ball and pool.
What you want to do is you want to have
that cemented in your mind when he calls
greasing the groove,
like each time you do it,
you'd do it perfect.
You do it with perfect form and you just
do low repetitions with heavyweights.
Absolutely.
You know Pablo and trump first.
But if it's another amazing,
it's cool.
Yes.
And one of my coach of strength
conditioning.
Yeah.
And yeah,
that's what I do for myself.
He didn't even because of those flights,
you know,
my jet lag,
my cns machine,
none of the assistant medical already
what I do when I train,
I never,
I'd maybe I'll every four week I tried
to do one or two reps and 95 percent.
I never tried to do a personal record.
I always liked to work like 85 percent
few reps show.
Even psychologically I know that I can
enter the good form at that level and
never got out
for people who are interested in this.
Go go to a pavle has a lot of stuff
online,
but I think some of the best stuff
online is him on the Tim Ferriss
podcast.
Really
excellent stuff and you know,
he's got his own books out there and
he's got books on tape and he's got
videos and you could see a lot of his
videos,
but his method is so good.
It's so.
It's so smart and it's made big
differences with me.
First of all,
it's cut my injuries down radically,
like radically because I would be doing
these,
you know,
12,
15 repetitions with heavyweight and like
barely getting the 13th one and then the
14th and then you know,
your forum gets all fucking sloppy.
Your back's bending in a weird way.
It's terrible for you.
It would be terrible.
We've been totally that.
Just,
you know.
Yeah,
no pain,
no gain.
That was shit.
No,
that's not how you,
it's so dumb.
But now I'm lucky that I have weights at
home so I have kettle bells at home so I
can do it four days a week,
five days a week and I'll work out for
an hour.
I'll just go in there.
It's 8:00 in the morning.
I start lifting,
I'm done in an hour and I'm not even
exhausted.
Not only am I not exhausted,
I feel kind of pumped up and kind of
charged,
but I'm not like,
oh,
like I used to work out sometimes,
like back in the day I would do lifts
and uh,
by the time the lift was over,
my fault,
I was light headed,
my legs were shaking,
I could barely walk and you don't have
any energy left to do things and I've
try to go to Jujitsu.
Hilarious.
I would just get mauled,
just couldn't do it,
you know,
it'd be fucking wrecked for like two or
three days.
So I'd be really nervous to lift in the
morning and then do Jujitsu at night
because I would know that I was going to
be operating at like 50 percent or 60
percent.
I'll just get my ass kicked.
But if you do kettle bells with low
repetitions,
even with heavy weight,
you could do a real good workout.
And then that night you could work
Jujitsu and you can be 100 percent close
to a bluff.
Pavel,
Pavel Tatsumi will tattoo you in touch
with Leni Habib.
He also wanted like,
he doesn't,
he wants you to finish the Kettlebell
workout energized.
He doesn't want you to finish it.
He doesn't want that at all.
I read that.
That's this whole thing.
God wants you to finish.
They're ready to go take on the world.
And I tell you I was,
I called Joe or they go joe,
you to go,
you gave me the kettle bells.
I love doing cleans.
I love doing the gun slings,
but you know,
I try to do 10 sets of 10,
12 swings and 10 minutes and I would do
that and I've achieved my goal and I'd
be very happy.
But then I couldn't go to Jujitsu for
three days.
Yeah.
So what the fuck did I do?
I'm 53,
you know,
but I would go,
I did it,
that had five sets of cleans with two
fives and then a jump rope and then try
to do setups and then for three days of
dog shit,
dog shit.
And I called him up and he goes,
go cut it in half.
And then I said,
you know what?
I'm only going to do my weights now.
On the road when I go to a hotel now,
every two weeks I work every other week
I'll hit the dumbbells and do the
elliptical,
but when I'm in town I'll just do the
tactile,
the beginning,
a little it Jujitsu and then
I'd do attack with at the end.
And you know what man,
I don't want to walk around hunched up
when I'm 60.
I got a four year old.
I got to be around and be.
I liked it.
I could touch my toes,
you know,
I like all this stuff.
But one thing I noticed about tax fit
that there's a couple movies that they
put in there.
I don't know if you did it or somebody
did that,
that Jujitsu friendly.
Oh yeah.
Like the moving movement to know if you
look at when you look,
even the kids rolling around when is a,
his early stage.
You go through something like,
you know,
double as they can transfer machine box
or whatever.
You can go into the rolling into the
garden.
So we got to talk to them like,
oh sorry.
So sorry.
So again you can see moving his moment.
So what we would start to do it start to
analyze those moments and try to get a
mechanical information about those
moments.
Yeah.
But the APP,
they apply very well on transition for
some Jujitsu and that's another things
that are bad.
There was no,
it was blowing his mind.
Say if I get the guys to move better,
it's easier for me to pass the technique
because they,
they,
of course,
they already know it.
One of the things that Eddie founders,
that guys who are break dancers,
yes,
excelled in Jujitsu.
And uh,
there's a kid who fought this past
weekend,
landover Nada in Orlando.
Vanana groovy.
Lando fought this past weekend.
He fought David Tamer.
Crazy fight was a co main event.
Lando has only been striking for six
years and,
but he's phenomenal.
But what happened was he started with a
BMX background.
He was a pro bmx racer and was like
apparently like a national champion and
bmx and that pumping,
pumping bike legs,
you know,
just be being able to like,
like generate extreme speed off the
line.
He developed as explosive ability to use
his legs.
And so that like having cross training,
whether it's through tack fit or whether
it's through yoga or whether it's two
kettlebells or break dancing or anything
else.
Shaka for Aldo.
Oh yeah.
Soccer for all those bridges,
sprinting,
they do.
And all the kicking they do in soccer.
The learning how to move your body.
Like look at what's going on with conor
mcgregor that ido parked out there.
He's concentrating so much on movement
and movement is just a huge factor in
his success because his ability to
dictate like where first of all its
ability to move in and out is better
than almost anybody's.
His ability to get out of the way and
his ability to move in close and move
like a fucking snake like is on the
outside and boom he's in and he's in
before you know it.
And these,
these complicated sort of tricky moves
to try to time and follow.
Very,
very difficult guy to time.
And a lot of that comes from constant
application of all this movement theory
and movement training.
And like the more you can move your body
any way you want,
the more you're going to be able to move
your body any way you want.
And competition.
Absolutely.
And you know,
at the end of the day,
like you said at the beginning of this
a,
you can call it Tashi,
Sfg Ido,
as long as the coach,
the coach is in the coaching charge,
it really smart.
They understand how to map you down.
That's good.
Yeah.
And in the Alamo that curse on,
we're talking about what he's into his
all plyometrics man.
He barely has these guys lifting
weights.
He's got guys jumping over hurdles and
stuff and doing all these leap,
leaping back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth like he's all
about movement and in a plyometric way,
in an explosive way.
And that's one of the reasons why he
gets such great results out of his
fighters is because they,
they developed this extraordinary
ability to close the distance,
extraordinary ability to get out of the
way,
you know,
the ability to move and then to stop
what you're doing.
And then counter quickly,
you know,
all that stuff is just so giant cross
fit fit into everything we're discussing
right now because every studio city is
the fucking capital crossfit might know
you can't go anywhere in studio city
without seeing five guys my age rather
than down the street with a 50 pound
plate over the head.
And I'm sitting there going,
something's not right here.
What do you think
I've done in my what I think,
you know,
I think crossfit at the beginning as
brilliant idea,
it was bringing back a lot of things.
They were disappearing like Olympic
weightlifting and gymnastic and stuff.
So I think it was good.
You started to ruin the things when the
games came is when this become a really
an official sport and people that just
get crazy,
you know,
it's a competition.
So they just training with that goal.
I need to beat the time,
I need to be depth things and they don't
understand,
you know,
this is going to kill you at that speed,
that,
that timing.
It's going to be too much.
Yeah.
But it needs 10.
Those ligaments and muscles at times to
adopt,
and if you take an hour,
a weightlifter,
he spent an entire life to do devcon to
learn that kind of moment perfectly.
Never,
never screw the movement and how many
reps he does in his competition.
One can die.
He can do that kind of a movement so
fast,
you know,
even if you lose the weight because you
can control one to three reps,
then you might be using app.
I was talking to Michael.
Michael was one of the most successful
crossfit coach,
especially here in southern California.
He used to have on as a big crossfit gym
and in vanize so and it was telling me
about he has more experience with me.
Of course.
Cross with that was his business told
me,
I believe that if you do,
you do when you are 20 years old or
something like this into the 30,
you can speak a little bit.
Then if you are smart enough,
you understand that,
then you need to slow down.
If you train cross without thinking cap
time,
try to see online how much this guy did.
So I want to beat this guy and just
training smartly.
You do your weight lifting your rings
and when it's got to be good it's going
to be,
but if you just to as a sport is just
conditioning you for that part such as
crossfit.
You can conditioning Fujitsu,
try to do at crossfit would with a cap
time because like you say,
you're going to be destroyed saying cup
time.
What does that mean?
Now in our captain is like,
okay,
you're supposed to do this and let's say
word Wod,
workout of the day,
kind of the entertainers.
Let's say you're supposed to finish in
30 minutes.
Really?
You made me,
for me,
it take 25 minutes,
about 25 minutes because I know that I
can control my movement and not going to
get an injury,
but most of the people they go online
because now there's want to see how much
time and it was telling me is crazy.
They need to rebuild the site,
the website,
and put more,
more,
more power because people,
they go when they wake up in the
morning,
you're going to see,
okay,
what is the word of the day this time?
Then when they go,
they go to work,
they're going to go online again and
see,
okay,
east coast is already probably did all
right.
That's the average time.
Alright,
so I'm going back the time and I
finished work.
They go online again to see,
okay,
now east coast,
this time now I go to the gym,
I try to do and put my time in the day.
In the evening I go like to see if
someone beat me.
So they go into this loop thing that
they want to compete,
compete,
compete for time,
and you're going to kill yourself.
Well,
Steve Maxwell said that he believes that
when you're doing is when you're lifting
and you're doing these Olympic lifts,
you should be doing a live make lefts to
get you stronger for another sport,
for a competition.
He doesn't believe that it should be a
sport in itself.
Right.
And he also said that I don't,
he doesn't believe in Olympic lifts for
high repetition.
He's like,
you're.
It's just a recipe for injury because if
you're doing cleans and presses,
he goes,
you watch Olympic lifters,
they do one wrap,
right?
Yeah.
They're not doing it 30 times in a row
and you know it.
Can it be done?
Yes.
You know what else can happen?
You could drop that weight on your head
and die because your body's failing
because you're,
you know,
you did 14 reps and everybody's going,
come on,
come on Alberto.
One morning
and your arms just literally give out.
And that thing paralyzes you.
That has happened.
It has happened.
It's about,
like you're saying,
it's the sport.
So if you want to do a game show
competition,
you need to train that way,
need.
Well there's guys that can do it.
And they do do it.
You know,
there's those rich froning guy that has
the winds that every year there's guys
that can do it and they do do it.
But you,
the person who's listening to this,
the average human being,
you are way better off following like a
strong first method,
you know,
or like your method or Pavle teaches
where you're,
you know,
you,
you lift the weights,
but you don't go to failure.
Use great technique.
And if you want to get endurance,
run up a fucking hill.
Okay,
go do rounds on a heavy bag.
You want endurance,
do sprints and a heavy bag.
You know what I do?
I have a timer and it times,
etc. For three minutes and every 30
seconds a buzzer goes off.
So there's a bell and then every 30
seconds is a buzzer.
And when those 30 seconds hit eat
Fucking sprint.
So it's 30 seconds,
boom,
boom.
Just go fucking crazy for 30 seconds and
the next buzzer hits.
So the next 30 seconds is so light and
the next 30 seconds I'm just sorta going
through the motions.
I'm kicking and punching,
but,
and I'm waiting for that fucking buzzer
and that buzzer goes off.
And then I go off again.
They just do that.
If you want endurance,
that'll give you phenomenal endurance,
but strength I am of the opinion,
and this is just from the last few years
of me operating this way,
that you should do low repetitions and
he should do it more often.
Absolutely.
I agree with you.
That's what I do for me.
And I got better.
I got stronger than before and I,
and I,
I took my hormone truck,
trucker and understand I took my
cortisol level test and a lower lower
just to train like that.
Your stress lower wraps?
No,
no.
How do you schedule your own personal
workouts?
Do you,
do you have someone do it for you or do
you decide based on how your body's
feeling,
do,
uh,
do to myself.
I did to myself and it's dependable.
I have my schedule about a much driving.
I need to cover a specific topic,
a lot of traveling,
talking about that,
that's an issue.
For example,
just for january,
from january 10 now I've been in
Australia and being back in Italy.
Then I went back to Brazil,
Brazil,
back to Italy,
Italy,
Panama,
Mexico,
Mexico.
Yet.
Then I go back to it and then I go back
to Korea.
Oh jesus,
it's happening this week.
I'm here next week.
I'm in maybe new in Australia.
And so it's crazy for me.
That's why I really very careful about
the way they're trained and sleep too.
I bet.
Right.
fucks with your sleep and all that
traveling.
So then like I was telling joy,
uh,
used a lot of melatonin,
of course,
melatonin,
phosphatidylserine to reduce my cortisol
level,
you know,
try to try to plan,
okay,
I'm going to land in this place.
The time zone iS different and try to
adjust my meals or the time zone,
you know,
tied to my training so I can set up.
It's pretty complicated for me to stay
in decent shape and debrief vitamins
with you.
Yeah,
I guess I got vitamin c and vitamin d
and he a lot.
And uh.
What about like as far as your diet,
like what do you concentrate on?
do you concentrate on eating a lot of
vegetables?
I actually try super green on
greg because you take it with you.
I don't like greens
someplace you go.
It's crazy.
Didn't you ask for veggies,
they all the things that gave you?
Yeah,
it's a couple of things that's easy for
me to put it in my shake or whatever.
Water,
vegetables,
so god damn.
Okay,
so important for people and so many
people,
they don't have it in
their diet.
They mess up and your body just does not
have those nutrients and it starts
drawing them out of your body.
It takes it out of your bones.
It takes out of your muscle and also
you're just not recovering correctly.
You're not developing correctly.
What do you get your produce?
Trauma.
I mean,
that's the dumbest question.
Tomatoes don't taste like tomatoes no
more,
joe.
Well,
that's because the tomatoes that you get
in the grocery stores are designed to
last longer.
They're not designed to taste good.
Oh,
but I could if you
do as much as I got up yesterday,
early one kind of forum.
I try as much as I can mean I can't.
I crave tomatoes,
heirloom tomatoes,
joy,
they look ugly.
They taste amazing.
No,
I got it.
They only last like a few days.
A few days ago.
That's the problem because they're real
tomatoes,
they're not these fucking franken
tomatoes.
They're hard and they're pale.
It cut into them like,
what is this a tomato or is this an app?
Like,
what the fuck is this?
It's weird and you know that they only
do it so that they could keep them on
those trucks longer and drive around the
country with them and keep them on the
shelves and the grocery store produce
yet.
Yeah,
we grow our own vegetables,
tomatoes,
we grow tomatoes,
we grow kale,
squash,
we grow cucumbers.
We grow a lot of things.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
if you can,
you should do it.
It's,
it's very satisfying to make a salad out
of something that you grew yourself and
just super healthy,
you know,
where it came from,
we buy real healthy fertilizer,
good soil,
you know,
and I think good soil is really
important to.
Um,
I hAve a friend who lived in brooklyn
and he got a soil tested.
It turned out that the ground was
contaminated with lead from back when
they used to have lead gasoline when
they had leaded gasoline.
Like all that shit goes up in the air
and it all comes down,
it's in your soil and it was in his soil
and there's different plants that you
could plant that will draw it out of the
soil.
Or the best solution I think is if you
have a yard,
just get potted plants,
just get those big wooden boxes and grow
the plants in there.
That's the best way because then you can
completely control what soil they grow
in.
And then,
you know,
it's,
it's just a very contained environment.
So that's how we do it.
We have these big potters and you know,
we grow watermelons and all kinds of
course,
because that would be my world to become
an old italian man.
Roll up your pants,
get a synagogue and oh,
I'd love it.
I love it right now.
Over right now everything's so green out
here.
It's so amazing.
Beautiful.
Because it's amazing.
It's amazing.
He's been around in there like crazy.
Yeah.
We had a drought for five years and then
this year it's just been flooded.
They had a giant break of a dam in
sacramento.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
I was in Panama.
What happened?
Yeah,
it's fucking awesome.
Awesome.
There's this thing called the glory
hole.
The morning glory hole up northern
California.
It'S this crazy hole that's in this lake
and it hadn't operated in 10 years.
It hadn't been doing it because it's
like this,
like a vortex,
like a,
what do they call those when it spins
like that?
What do they call it?
A textbook.
So it's sucks this whole somehow or
another when the water level gets to a
certain point,
it develops as whole.
And this lake and it wasn't there for 10
years and now it's finally back again
for the first time.
Oh yeah,
there it is.
Isn't that nuts?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So for 10 years the water level wasn't
high enough for that actually to be
happening and now it's finally happening
again.
People were all excited,
so it's pretty much over all of the.
The drought issues that we had here in
California are pretty much all tell this
fucking guy,
I don't care what tv they get this get
rid of this god that we were waiting on
this other tv for so long.
Tell him today,
say,
just get whatever the fuck you can get
by saturday because we have a fight
companion on saturday.
We can't have this happening.
Um,
but anyway.
Yeah.
So you take a protein protein?
Honestly,
no,
I very rarely to protein if I have to,
like if I'm running and I'm low on food,
I haven't eaten anything but I know I'm
going to work out.
Um,
I like hemp protein because I can take
like a glass of hemp protein with
coconut water and I could,
I could work out in 30 minutes,
like no problem because it digests so
easily.
It's Just goes right into your system.
So easy.
It's a nice light.
It's only,
you know,
you're only dealing like 16 grams of
protein.
It's nothing too crazy.
But most of my protein I get from meat
or real food.
That's what we were discussing in the
car.
Yeah,
I do.
If I'm on the plane and I didn't get the
chance to cook my food and things of the
plane,
man,
I got some product.
But otherwise I like to get some old
food.
If I knew I was traveling and I couldn't
get it,
I bring a lot of bars with me.
I bring these,
um,
there's a company called primal kitchen.
This guy mark sisson,
and he makes these.
Yeah,
he makes these amazing bars because
they're very low sugar.
So when I called five grants sugar.
Yup.
He's got the coconut.
He's got um,
cashews and coconuts.
He's got almonds and dark chocolate.
This is there some back therapy,
more trouble by god.
He's got a coconut
dog.
He's got a vanilla coconut meal
replacement.
Oh yeah.
It's very good.
I could drink this at seven in the
morning.
Me smoke and eat till two.
I don't need to have to jujitsu a drink.
That protein powder because I mixed them
up.
I used to have,
I use that,
like if I have a long,
like today I drank the cocoa because I'm
not going to be out of here till two.
You sent me hungry.
You see me fidgeting?
No,
it's the real fucking deal.
The key is low sugar.
That is the key to eliminate as much
sugar in your diet.
And by the way,
folks,
that includes fruit juices,
if you thinking that you're drinking a
big glass of orange juice in the morning
and it's healthy.
So worst thing ever.
It's so crazy.
We thought that was healthy for so long.
For so long we thought,
oh,
I'm drinking a nice healthy orange
juice.
Squeezed through that whole scenario.
they may see,
oh,
we got cereal.
I don't need carbohydrateS.
Sugar.
The more sugar you can cut out of your
diet,
the better.
And sunday is my cheat day.
Yesterday I had pizza.
I had a cuban sandwich.
I had a q,
a cuban sandwich that uh,
um,
it was a fucking delicious.
What is,
it wasn't the movie right in the cif
chef?
Yes.
But I didn't see chef.
But what a chef.
They had a cuban restaurant in movies.
That was that movie with bradley cooper.
Is that three people shot?
Oh,
he makes up a food truck,
a soul food truck.
I love with bradley cooper.
Something else with him now.
No one saw that movie.
He didn't even see that movie.
Somebody pulled the people that made the
people that edited that movie fell
asleep.
That's a unique thing on my page.
Joe,
you got to show you.
They put this thing about a restaurant
in New York city.
It's called.
I've been there.
It's called like golly,
that is the last cuban chinese
restaurant and really excited states,
cuban chinese.
Joe,
you got to.
They have one last and his name is
antonio wong and the guy joe,
you got to put the thing.
I'm pleased.
So there's a.
there's a chinese community is huge.
The biggest chinatown before fidel
chinatown on the outlets outside of
China,
but the people that were born there
started talking chinese in Cuba.
So when I was growing up you had like,
I'm fine.
I cina which is the chinese bell on 57th
and bergen line,
but the real deal one was this last one
called lacan either and yet somebody put
it on my page yesterday and we will
watch look at this,
but they have.
So they have a chinese eco bada
[inaudible] yo yo,
yo.
Yo.
Yo means what?
They look at it fried bananas,
fried rice.
This is in New York?
Yeah.
See if you can find the video.
Jim,
and they put it on my facebook page.
We need to go next time.
We're in New York and we do all the
time.
When he was in New York,
they're open killed too,
but the restaurant already,
by the way.
You have Vietnam?
Yeah,
it was in Vietnam.
They got photos of him,
but before that I met him on the fucking
beach somewhere before that he was
entitled.
That was a month ago.
He can't be somewhere else.
Can anImal.
He's crazy.
His phone still off the hook.
He was supposed to be back a month ago
that nobody knows where he is.
He's not coming back until may.
May.
May is one of the shoot.
The shoot,
is that what he said?
He's not coming back to a man.
I don't.
I don't think.
I don't think we'll see him next month
or even hear from him next month.
What a weirdo could you do that could
you vanished for months and just not
talk to anybody?
None of this.
He's not talking to any of his best
friends were his best friends.
He's not talking to us.
Not talking to anybody.
Maybe talking like one dude.
Maybe he's got a confidant
when duty calls up.
Hey man,
I'm only calling you see gabriel
iglesias.
Cool.
What?
What's he doing?
Canceled this tour.
What?
Why?
Okay.
This tool.
But why do you cancel?
Was trying to use.
Looked at a headshot of myself.
Ten years passed by don.
That's what he said.
So how about damon apolis app apple.
this manager looked at me and said talk
sense into him police.
But what dId he say?
What?
What's this thought process?
Just working too much.
He worked.
He needs to.
He's joined a boxing class.
He joined solstice classes.
Really just wants to live.
She just wants to live.
They bought that new mustang.
Joe.
That that's a bad motherfucker.
Which one?
Which one did you go to?
The one that they made 77 of them.
Oh,
the shelby gt.
Three 50.
How many horsepower?
Pretty high.
It's just too much shit that you don't
really need.
They only made 77 of them,
so he's going to go,
I'm writing this fucking cars and he's
got a shit load of money.
Gabriel,
he's got a shit load of cars so he's
wants to do something with jay and
they're got to drive cars and wave at
people,
goes out the window.
You know,
I've been thinking about this myself,
man,
because of my ufc contract is going to
be up again.
Uh,
I only have,
I do it one year at a time now.
I used to sign these long ass contracts,
like five years,
but now I'm like,
I'm not doing that anymore.
I'm going year by year and I have to
decide soon because my contract's up
again in august.
I don't know what I'm going to do,
but I do too many things.
I do too much.
I work too much,
you know,
and the family really wears on it.
And we were talking about date night on
fridays.
I got,
I got the bill of lading sent that once
they give you the bill of lading that
makes sense over the,
the act of the act of 2017 that the dea
is household friday night.
His wives dog give a fuck about you.
Stand up no more.
I gotta get out here.
I got a four year old that drives me
crazy.
So friday night's date,
night to official.
You know what man,
you and I have been talking about this
too,
that in town it's maybe sometimes even
best to not go out on the weekends and
work because even though it's good to
work and it's good to like get your
standup and on the weekends everybody's
there to see the big show.
Right.
But for us,
especially now for me it's only a couple
months.
It's my special came out.
And for you it's just a month and a
half.
Right.
When did your special come out?
Three months ago.
December,
right?
Yeah.
So for me it's three months to.
Um,
so when,
when that happens,
or four months when that happens,
your shit comes out and then you're in
this scramble mode where you're trying
to create.
And what I like,
what you're doing is you're going to
these hole in the walls,
goes weird places and show up and work
your material out.
And these joints,
you go to the comedy store on a friday
night,
there's 400 fucking people.
It's packed to the gills and everybody's
doing their best 15 minutes over and
over and over again.
And one of the things that I noticed
when I went there recently,
a lot of these guys that aren't doing a
specials,
you know,
there's a lot of young guys coming up in
particular that they don't have any
specials.
They,
they're not releasing any materials.
So they're doing the same material every
time.
I see them for fucking years now,
for two years when I've been coming
there.
There's certain comedians that have been
doing the same act every time I work
with them.
So what they're doing is they're
tightening up this hard 15 minutes and
they're doing it all the time.
And you know how to do that 15 minutes.
I don't think that's helping you.
And I don't think it's a lot of ways is
not helping me.
They're like,
what would really help?
Because you do long sets on the road.
If you go somewhere and you're doing an
hour and you do have two shows on a
friday,
two shows on a saturday,
that's what helps.
That's where it's at.
It's a the podcast.
Because just the way my office building
is,
I don't,
I can't go in there in the daytime and
smoke a pound in the pot and played loud
music.
I just can't do it.
And I don't want to do it.
So I prefer to do it at night when I'm
going to have a gun to my head.
You know,
if I come here at 1:00,
joe,
and we have to sit here till four,
from three to four,
I'm going to be fidgety or out of
control because I'm thinking about that
fucking traffic.
I want you to do podcast.
I don't want you to think of nothing.
I don't want you to think of nothing,
bro.
If you got a spot,
don't do my podcast because we might go
on a tangent.
That's brilliant.
Yeah,
and you got to leave for a stupid
fucking spot.
I've no,
don't do it that monday.
Then I tried to do comedy two,
three times a week,
but now I'm doubling up.
What do you do?
You have a guest this wednesday
for your podcast?
Because I was supposed to do it.
I'm supposed to do at one of these
times.
We'll figure it out.
Tell me one so I could cancel whatever
comedy I got you.
Yeah.
What days are you doing it?
Mondays and wednesdays.
So you got tonight?
No,
I'm not doing it tonight.
How come?
Because I did it last night.
Uh,
I did two yesterday.
Oh nice.
Nice.
Did the undercover cop finally.
Oh,
how was that joe fucking to be close to
a killer for 18 months.
We sprays sinai and your face.
That's what he was doing.
He was chasing this guy that was the ice
man,
right?
He was chasing the ice man.
So he had a medium and the iceman for
the only reason why the ice made contact
with him was because he heard he could
get different guns and you know,
he was atf.
So when the ice man contacts me,
he wanted sinai.
So he kept saying bring me the sinai and
then he was going to sell him arms.
So for 18 months this guy had contact
with this guy.
I had met him,
meet him at a diner,
he said he would hold his gun,
pointed right at him when he would meet
with him under the table or under the
table.
But you also had to sit outside.
You always tell them to sit outside
because he didn't want to be downwind of
the sinai just in case he's because he
just sprayed in your face,
you're done.
So he was always worrying this guy was
going to ice them,
like literally isom literally.
Wow.
And then he would kill it.
You call me ice man.
For people who don't know,
he,
uh,
would kill somebody and then throw them
in the freezer in his basement for like
seven,
eight months.
So they disappear.
And then he put them in this fucking
basement and then he would toss the body
somewhere so it confused the fuck out of
people.
They didn't know when the guy died
because it would thaw out.
And then they be like,
why is this kind of frostbite on them?
What the fuck is this guy's intestines?
The fresh?
Yeah,
like his intestines were still fresh.
Meanwhile the guy had disappeared six
months ago,
so they call them the ice man.
And he kept these fucking people in his
basement.
You know how cold blooded you have to be
the
you're going to sleep in your basement.
You got to.
Did he do in his basement?
They have a warehouse where he has a
warehouse in north bergen,
New Jersey where I'm from right out
newkirk.
I got my dick sucked out their time by
gabby.
Right out there.
I saw gabby driving on kennedy boulevard
and I just stopped the and she goes,
what do you need a ride like,
gabby,
can you suck my dick?
She goes,
get in
good kid.
And then,
uh,
he killed.
Like is richard kuklinski right?
He had killed the.
I lived on,
given that terrorists and on charles
court there was a guy named mr.
Softy.
He had an ice cream truck and that was
his partner until he killed him too.
He killed all his fucking partners.
He killed a lot of fucking people and he
killed a lot of people for the gambino
family.
Right.
Wasn't that who?
He worked for him,
but he was doing shit that it just
wasn't like.
They asked them one time about he
bought.
He bought a bow and arrow.
He bought a bow and arrow,
one of the ones that you have like a gun
across and the guy says,
how do you know what was going to work?
It was just go for a ride.
There was a guy that light with a
motorcycle helmet.
He shot him right now,
man just took off because it works.
He was one of those dudes that just
didn't care and that's what this guy was
saying.
Yes,
it goes,
you really don't know that this.
He goes,
that one day my kid was halloween and he
had the horns on at the house and I had
to tell the kit to take them off because
in reality I was sitting across from
this guy every day this guy would talk
about murder,
like the way you talk about lifting
weights,
like I shot him in the throat and he
didn't really die.
So I look at,
you know,
just shit that's just,
you gave me that book,
murder machine.
You remember that book?
Jesus christ,
that's a fucking scary book and it
details this guy who was a um,
a mob boss,
was it in the seventies,
in the seventies,
and this,
it details how he slowly started killing
a bunch of people,
like slowly but surely.
And then they would cut them up in their
fucking bathtub and then they had this
one apartment where they would take
these people to,
that was above this bar that they would
go to.
They take these people upstairs and
fucking kill him and they killed so many
people.
But you know,
there were animals because it wasn't
even for business anymore.
It was like he disrespected me like it
would listen to me called my sister fat.
Really?
You gotta walk them upstairs.
They'd shoot them and stuff and they'd
hang them and they'd cook.
Yeah,
and they'd wait for the body to drain.
Yeah.
They would cut the neck and hang them
and so that the blood would drain out of
it.
Go in and chop them up and put them
around.
Who does this shit fucking sleep at
night.
You know what I'm saying?
I could see somebody calls you a
motherfucking.
You shoot them.
Shit happens.
You know somebody owe you $10,000.
Somebody hits your sister with caught,
but the just.
They were just doing shit to prove that
they were animals.
That's animal shit.
Well,
I think what happens is you get used to
doing it just like we were talking about
fighting and the more you fight,
the more you get comfortable with it.
I think there's something that happens
to people when they kill people.
They get real comfortable with it and
the more comfortable they get with it,
the easier it is.
And then they start getting a rush out
of doing it and there's also this power
to know that this guy walking around and
you know,
his wife thinks he's coming home and
you're like,
you know what,
you're not coming home.
I'm going to just stop this right now.
And that it's almost like they get a
thrill out of playing god in a lot of
ways.
You know,
he was,
you know,
I read the,
before I spoke to him,
he told me to read a different book.
I had read a different book on the ice
man.
And he told me to read a different book.
And again,
this was our conversation earlier.
What book did you read?
Uh,
it was,
it was a different author.
This one was by anthony,
brutal called the iceman.
The one I had read before,
carl was by a different office.
Something called up and they said he
had,
he had caught the iceman later when he
had become more exaggerated,
I killed kennedy because towards,
do you have any killed everybody.
He was dead when
he found out that he was getting
people's deckard.
So this guy wrote the early,
when it's really weird,
you know,
his dad just beat the shit out of them,
beat the shit out of the mother jersey
city.
Yeah.
It just made him a monster,
you know,
there's no depth between jersey city and
hoboken,
new work,
same animals.
And he said that there was a kid that
would always call them polk.
He had to wear the same clothes to
school every day.
You had no money,
you know,
and uh,
the kid caught,
he described his first murder.
You know how he got a stick and waited
for the kid to come home.
He was 14,
you know,
when you kill somebody at 14.
I thought he killed a guy at a bar with
a.
I thought he killed a guy,
strangled him.
That was the member.
He lit the one guy on fire like he
wants.
But the first guy he got was this young
guy and he wouldn't give his name.
He beat him up with the two by four.
And he went upstairs and the next
morning the cops were outside.
He thought he just drew a beating on
him.
He didn't know he killed him,
so he was scared.
He kept puking and he kept going to
school and thinking that people would
know and after that that's it.
Once you get away with it,
it's like a,
what's the taste,
the taste tastes in your mouth.
And then he started going.
He had an argument with a guy over pool
and he beat him in the head with a pool
cue 30 fucking times and then he got
into another beef where he shot the guy
outside,
but we left the car on fire with the
body in it.
You know,
the reason why there's so many
unexplained.
That's because his first couple of years
he was going out at night,
you know,
there was a time when I had four drinks
and I go rob something you believe that
just the drinks would get you feel
loose.
And like I was great until I had four
drinks and then I'd be walking home,
let's see,
a store.
And I kicked the door opening for some
fucking reason,
you know?
Wow.
He would go out and kill,
can kill people at night,
like go somewhere and let's see.
He just insulted them for the weirdest
thing,
like,
hey,
get out of the way.
He would wait for you outside and shoot
you.
So that's how he developed his things.
Was that episode available now?
Which one?
The one with this dough.
Put it up yet.
When is that one going up this week I'm
going to do a wraparound the router,
because it was a phone call,
right,
so I just take the phone call was sunday
and then we'll do a wrap around and
compare it to the book.
He's a great guy.
I really had a great guy.
I mean I got to talk to him every day.
He's like 70,
but he's essex county.
Went to the university of Nebraska,
was a golden gloves champion,
went back,
became a state cop,
then they became atf.
Just a fucking great story.
There was two guys that were talking
about your podcast.
It was fucking hilarious.
They were talking about lee lee,
cya,
and they were like,
what joey has done to that poor guy,
and he's like,
every time he sees him he's forcing them
to eat mushrooms.
He's got to take asset.
He's given them pot.
He's given them edibles.
He's lied to them about the dosage.
Lead.
Loves it.
He loves it.
He does.
He did the.
We did that liquid acid with the ice
cube with the sugar cubes.
Jesus christ.
But two weeks ago we did two nights in a
row.
Was hilarious on the show.
He did it and then he called me the next
day.
He's like,
that was fun.
I went to cps at four in the morning.
He wasn't like that before he met you
though?
No,
but he's having a great to turn that kid
into a freak.
He's not a freak man.
I turned them into a functioning savage,
but I love him.
Like I love him with all my heart
because he makes me.
He makes me laugh so much joe.
Like he just,
you know,
I'm 54.
It's 28.
He's half my age.
Right.
You know,
I see life from his perspective,
you know,
and I'm like when you guys get along
together,
great.
It's like a great dynamic.
The two of you together,
it works really well.
Oh,
I love it.
I don't see him too much during the week
so I keep the relationship fresh.
We taught all the time.
I torment them all.
The dad called him.
I go,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
It was,
what are you talking to?
My buddy just got a letter from the
state.
Why is your fucking phone tapped?
I taught math them for 20 minutes about
his phone,
but why?
Why?
Why my boeing fleet that I go,
do you work for the cia?
Is that been made you come over and take
my acid so you can report back?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Don't worry about it must have been a
mistake.
And the guy got me the liquid acid,
right?
I called him and I said,
listen,
I got a liquid ass.
I mean you could hear him getting
anxiety on the phone because I don't
know.
You could hear a little bit.
And then he goes,
how are we going to do it?
I said,
so we're going to get sugar cubes and
put the acid on it.
But I called them back.
I a daily.
I hadn't had no assets and I had no
sugar cubes.
I just made it up.
I go,
listen,
I just put the acid on the cube sugar
cubes and I put them in a tupperware and
I put a lid on it and I left.
And when I came back to lynn had blown
up.
So whenever that acid is going to be
really fucking strong,
I go,
I put aluminum foil over.
It would hold so it could breathe.
So the acid won't fucking go into.
Oh my god.
Had them gone for two weeks.
I go to cleveland.
Guess what?
Some guy comes up to me,
gives me a tube of this is the
pharmaceutical grade shit.
This will kill gaddafi.
I go home,
we put drops on his cue on need sugar
cube.
Oh my fucking god.
Yeah.
But see again,
that's why I quit everything because my
tolerance is too hot.
Back in the deck of the two drops.
Ipi for 12 hours,
seeing things,
unicorns.
I seen something like two hours.
But you,
who knows what,
how strong it really was to.
And you're getting it from cleveland.
You've got to get it from like northern
California.
Oh no,
no.
But then I lost.
I lost the 10 sheet from a guy in
england.
A guy in england gave me some stuff.
Pink floyd and I said this,
the same one that syd barrett took when
he quit pink floyd.
So I took that.
I saved that.
So now I'm going to get the liquid acid.
I'm going to put it on the blog or from
pink floyd and we're going to go deep.
I'm just saving that one for a good
guest.
I like it.
Well,
let's wrap this up.
Um,
so alberto,
how can people get ahold of you?
It's alberto galaxy on twitter and on
instagram,
right?
Yeah.
Go to a two l's and joey.
Obviously mad flavor and a mad flavor on
twitter and matt flavors.
World is like someone's running out for
you,
right?
Yeah,
lately
I thought it was a one by one podcast
guy who does what he does,
the instagram.
Oh,
okay.
The instagram.
Okay.
Leah does all the baltimore next week
with my main med.
John.
John rollins.
Where are you at?
Where you going?
But boobies just predates me and
thompson.
Thompson was the following week.
Oh,
beautiful.
Beautiful.
We're going to have a good time there
and.
Awesome.
And the podcast is the church of what's
happening now.
It's available on itunes.
Fucking great podcasts.
He's doing seminars everywhere and they
just do an on it and austin.
Oh beautiful.
When you're doing the honors seminar and
austin,
it would be in the middle of march,
which is this month.
So,
uh,
what,
what's your schedule?
Working so many.
Uh,
go find it.
What's the website?
Oh,
they can go to feet the academy or talk
for europe so they're can always find
me.
So.
Okay.
So they're just google your name and
stuff on youtube,
man.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
Appreciate it man.
Appreciate it.
Really,
really fun talking to brother joe.
See you guys tomorrow.
Bye.